[Laughter]
hey
everybody
it's friday look at you you got your hat
like all crooked like sexualized already
so early on in the show oh [ __ ] they're
out there sexualizing me
yeah who is unacceptable i don't know
man i feel like i don't feel them eyes
all over me
and it's men stop that [ __ ]
oh you love it
it's zach and his friends out there
well zach is there but he didn't say
anything specifically sexual he just
said
i'm not his attacker i'm not his dad
he he brings all his friends in here to
show show them to me or show me to them
that's what it is
does it make you feel like a specimen in
a zoo a little bit i'm just waiting
where the money is
i've got him out there
got him out there trying to pin me out
and [ __ ] you know what i mean where's
where's the flash bulbs
where's the super chats
you should come on like this and your
little panties and stuff like that and
like you know thrust your groin at the
camera and stuff like that yeah there
you go
opening that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i was nine say we're like less than five
minutes and you're already taken up here
i'm in a good mood you know well that's
good
and you haven't been pre-gaming he
didn't usually you would go to the oasis
on friday but you didn't today
no i'm just starting right now so we're
just starting right now so we're on the
same we're on an even keel he doesn't he
hasn't he's not like four or five drinks
that'll be like usual no i'm actually
like more mellow when i'm [ __ ] have
more in me i'm [ __ ] a little more
hyped up in the beginning
it's gonna be a good show tonight
because we're just it's friday
we're not going out so we're gonna
[ __ ] drink right here
yeah these are always the funnest to do
we like we like drinking and hanging out
with you guys yeah and then we're gonna
uh probably watch some movies and in the
meantime we're gonna uh talk about
whatever you guys want to talk about we
can talk about food we could talk about
movies we could talk about paranormal
cases true crime cases talk about
[ __ ] current events uh answer
questions we can do whatever we want um
but right now i'm drinking rum and
jenny's drinking
vodka as a screwdriver yeah yeah i got
rum and passion fruit
that's why i'm so randy so early it's
always
[Laughter]
that's what it
is it's an aphrodisiac it's an
aphrodisiac
[Laughter]
he keeps like adjusting the angle of his
hands
that's how i that's how i adjust the
testosterone
it's the hat angle that's what it is
yeah that's what it is
i might have to change hats or change
sides
that looks a little bit yeah it's hurt
for a second that's when i went
australian on that side it wasn't even
that i was going to say you kind of
looked like
a combination of like popeye and maybe
like a [ __ ] up mime yeah like because
it kind of looked like a beret for a
second yeah because you couldn't see the
shape of it anymore
michael schaefer said passion fruit
you're losing your guy card see now
that's what i tell him all the time he
loves all that because okay here's the
thing so last night i grew up with it in
brazil man we went to i mean i don't
hate passion fruit it's just not my
favorite i like it it's not called
passion fruit in brazil
well obviously it's called well that
sounds much cooler yeah
much cooler yeah passion food that's an
american concept
i wonder where i now i'm kind of curious
as to like where that like particular
nomenclature came from like somebody
thought that it looked like a vagina or
something i'm sure and that's probably
the way that well they're probably
trying to sell it off of some kind of
[ __ ] aphrodisiac [ __ ] that's what i'm
saying but the in in brazil it's called
maracuja and there is there is a
matakuja everything ice cream
uh
mango and stuff like that is very south
america yeah yeah those flavors and
margarita candy [ __ ] uh
like this little [ __ ]
kind of like dried fruit you know how
you have like you know you know how you
you have like dry foods or dried
apricots yeah
they would like dry it but then they
would blend it and then
kind of candy it and repackage it
kind of like in bars kind of like the
center of say like a fig newton bar it's
like that but you could cut it
yeah i know yeah i've seen a fruit
roll-up i've seen that i think they sell
that here too but it is so [ __ ] good
man
he's we've kind of talked about this
before because you are a more like if
you're gonna get candy he always likes
like fruity candy yeah i grew up
i grew up so like tropical fruit man so
like last night we went to rifftrax live
at the movie theater yeah and he was
like well we're gonna we gotta go to
dollar general and see if they'll like
they got some cheap ass candy in there
so all kinds of cheap they had all kind
of cheap ass candy and you know like him
he's just like well they're only a
dollar each so he got like a [ __ ] ton
yeah gummies and then he's just like all
kind of like sour gummies and stuff and
then he has to like stuff him in like
all his pockets and stuff so
and you can see i had [ __ ] two big
old [ __ ] balloons hey you want some
gummy bears like that that's the gummy
bears i had that heartbroken uh [ __ ]
sour haribo harbour and then i had a
hearty brother i had horrible fruit
salad man that [ __ ] is good [ __ ] good
really see i don't like that like i said
i don't hate it but i'm always just kind
of like you know because i think i was
talking about this the other day it's
like you know i can't really eat a lot
of candy or treats or like that i mean i
can but i would get really fat
so
if i'm gonna have candy i want it to be
something i really really really like
and really want i don't want to use kind
of like [ __ ] fruity candy um just
because it's there
so i went and i said well i'm gonna get
also get a dollar bag of candy like to
take with me into the movies but i want
some like chocolate with nuts in it
because that's what i usually like so
they actually did have a bag of like uh
it was like milk chocolate and peanut
clusters and they were only a buck and
it was active it was actually really
good it was like not only was it decent
quality chocolate but there was a lot of
there was a lot of it in there it was
like so much that i could barely finish
this [ __ ] oh redneck [ __ ] redneck
[ __ ]
country ass dollar general store has got
good generic [ __ ]
but i just but i just got one bag and
then he's like why are you only getting
one bag i said because if i bought
five or six bags you'd be then i would
eat it all like over the next couple
days it's like i don't really want to
keep it in the house because i'll eat it
she's getting skinny
she's getting skinny she's well because
i haven't
literally all i've eaten today i've had
two cups of coffee with not even sugar
in it i've used sweet and low and so
i've had two cups of coffee and two
little
tacos like pork tacos she's getting
smaller around the waist her boobs get
[ __ ] huge when she's so small around
well i mean they don't really literally
get bigger yeah they were big but it's
uh you can see it's an optical illusion
it's not an illusion
it's a proportion thing the boots get
big again
[ __ ] um
it was like my first wife she was
[ __ ] like a hundred hundred pound
olive oil [ __ ] skinny
she went and got those [ __ ] 600 cc's
or 650cc implants
i mean those [ __ ] were chest bursters
they were [ __ ] no room in there
sorry sorry i just she walked in and
[ __ ] just huge man [ __ ] she'd come
in to the [ __ ] club and [ __ ] all eyes
were on her like [ __ ]
she could just rest her chin on top of
her [ __ ] boobs like that people
putting their drinks in the drinks
you can put the mail in there and hold
it she's proud of him though
that's really funny he's proud of him
yeah sorry when you said chest burster i
just i just had a
a mental image of somebody with like two
alien chest bursts out of each tit
because
jenny was always big you know she always
had big bows but [ __ ] my first wife
was [ __ ] flat she was flat and then
got those [ __ ] her sister got a pair
her sister was a stripper and she looked
[ __ ] fantastic and she's just i'm
gonna get some of those
yeah she got the same kind [ __ ] and
uh damn
that's why
i couldn't believe how quickly she was
just up running around because my first
wife she said it was like having two
guys [ __ ] sitting on her chest she
could barely breathe there was no room
in there she's
i had to keep her just like
basically knocked out for a week
on [ __ ]
i admit that i felt like that for five
or ten minutes when i first woke up
from the
from the surgery
but
then like i said i went to sleep for a
few hours and then when i woke up i
slept for like five or six hours and
then when i woke up i felt pretty much
fine yeah
no not tiff tiff was [ __ ] up for about
a week she's like knocked me out i just
can't take it i can't i had to [ __ ]
pick her up take her to the bathroom and
[ __ ]
because she just she couldn't even get
out of bed
you know man
well she just couldn't even [ __ ] move
yeah
i mean like i said it's probably like
because she didn't really have the so i
mean it was a lot more traumatic yeah
there's no room because they put them
underneath your muscles yeah so it's
like that takes like a lot of yeah
that's a lot of trauma to your body
she's okay walking out of there and then
got her in bed and then [ __ ] she
didn't she didn't wait every time she
woke up she was just like
oh oh you know it's okay they just kept
[ __ ] knocking her ass out and i she
barely ate
during that time mostly just fluids yeah
so you don't want to use this no i can't
eat you know
yeah it was rough so you just were
[ __ ] two days later if you're just
running around i think i went to work
the next day the next day you're like ah
it's no big deal i drove to work yeah
like 50 miles yeah jenny was already
like a d cup
it didn't really matter that's what i
mean it wasn't like yeah she's just
putting in an internal bra
[Laughter]
camp guy says i just read shawshank
redemption and apt pupil excellent
writing in those mid-career king
novellas yeah i really really do like uh
those two because those are that's um
those two are in different seasons are
they not like the one that has like four
novellas in there some of the shawshank
redemption yeah that wasn't that was a
short story was it well it's a novella
it's a novella right i remember reading
it yeah i was it's good and the the
novella is actually called rita hayworth
and shawshank reddit
because i it's been so long what year
was that
god that must have been no 80s lady i
think it's 80s early 80s yeah it's
before i went into the army
and uh i remember thinking at the time i
was reading it that it was a lot more
lucid than his normal [ __ ] i bet you he
wasn't on as many drugs
i don't know i was under the impression
that he was on all the drugs pretty much
up until the 90s okay
i could be totally wrong about that i
think he was drinking too he drank he
yeah coke and [ __ ] yeah he was an
alcoholic and a coke well that's kind of
why a lot of his
which to be honest it's like i'm not
saying that's a good thing but the fact
that his stuff was as lucid as it was
considering like when you found out
later like all the stuff that he was on
like
you go man yeah i think if i was that
drunk i wouldn't be able to like [ __ ]
write a coherent paragraph much less a
whole 800 page novel yeah so you know
i'm catching it with all the [ __ ]
everybody's talking
see what everybody's saying zach was
talking about uh carrie yeah i said what
i love about sissy's basic in that movie
is she's really pretty but also kind of
weird looking she was so perfect for
that role yeah i mean i can't imagine
anyone else playing that role and i know
that they've done it like i said with cl
uh what's her name uh chloe grace moritz
and she was good in the remake but
she's too i she's too pretty
like i i found it hard to believe like i
said that chloe grace moretz was picked
on
and i know that sometimes like good
looking people get picked on too like if
they have something else weird about
them but it just i didn't buy it as much
because i'm like yeah she's gorgeous so
i don't really get you know what i mean
but sissy's basic even though she's
actually quite pretty
you could understand like why people
would pick on her because like i said
she's pretty but she's like funny
looking she's not like classic pretty so
wow she was cute no i know like when and
even in carrie when they fit when they
fix her up and she goes to the prom and
she puts like makeup on and they do her
hair and she's in the pretty dress and
everything i think she's quite beautiful
actually
in the context of that particular movie
that they were picking on her because
she was big enough to pick on uh
sometimes if a person is really pitiful
they won't pick on them at all because
they feel sorry for them especially if
they're like you know in a wheelchair or
something like that she looked pretty
enough to pick on but she was weird
enough to pick on a lot of girls i knew
they were picked on were just weird
you know
yeah sometimes i think it's more
not fitting in like okay a tiff tiffany
my first wife she was picked on she's
gorgeous but she was picked on but it
was because
she didn't fit in
well i was going to show you a girl i
had the same thing and this was even
before like when i was in elementary
school i was not a weird-looking kid i
was actually quite a cute child if i do
say so myself i had like you know real
pretty red hair and everything like that
so i wasn't ugly or funny looking or
anything like that but i got picked on
because i was really quiet and really
shy and really bookish yeah and i wasn't
real social or real outgoing so i got
picked on because of that yeah yeah it's
kind of like it's kind of and and also
because um i went to school where the
kids were more like upper middle class
and i was very much working class
so a lot of times like i wore kind of
like secondhand clothes because they'd
been like passed down from other family
members so i kind of got picked on
because of that because it's like ooh
you're poor that kind of thing yeah tiff
is an
old school gulfport mississippi i mean
that was always a step up from the
central part of this gulfport
mississippi
um [ __ ] country type school and she
was a goth kid so you know i mean you're
gonna get picked off
i mean well yeah like after i went to
junior high yeah then i started getting
picked on for being i was talking about
elementary school
like before that even but like yeah
junior high when i started going like so
this is for camp guy right
yeah camp guy got your order done yeah
we're going to mail them out uh tomorrow
yep again um look got to put the little
labels on the back for you all right
and uh
came out good
these are extra large
now look i was gonna take care of you
man because you were very generous i
think [ __ ] you sent me 120 bucks last
night so i gave you another shirt
a whale and yutani but there's a caveat
on this one i didn't have any extra
larges so i mean those were the last two
extra this is the last one the last two
right there so i gave you this is this
one's a large
all right
so you can either just give it to
somebody you could uh lose some goddamn
weight
or it might fit on yeah i don't know but
uh no i'm just it might fit on you
anyway a lot of guys a lot of you guys i
know how guys are man they get they're
wearing the damn size bigger than they
really should be wearing a lot of times
and you can put on a size smaller in it
main difference is the length on those
things really
i can put a large on and it fits kind of
like this it's just that it's a [ __ ]
six inches longer
yeah it's kind of honestly with t-shirts
it's really hard to get a good fit right
because i tend to like ones that are
smaller
but i like ones that are smaller and
fitted but longer i don't really like
short t-shirts that drives me crazy
because i'm well because i'm really
short wasted so i like something that
kind of goes at least down to my hips so
like a lot of times you get into a
problem especially if you have big boobs
is that even if you get a small t-shirt
like it'll you know it might go down to
your hips but then after it goes over
your boobs then it's like too short if
you pay attention to the fashion gurus
by right you're supposed to have this is
ridiculous but it's true
those real fashion oriented
[ __ ] see what i mean who are
big into looking their best and spend a
lot of money on it have all their
t-shirts tailored
well yeah and i mean if i could afford
it i probably would want to
it makes a big difference because it's
just like i have like a [ __ ] ton of
t-shirts but there's really only a
handful of them that i really like the
way they fit like someone is like oh
they're a little too short or they're a
little too baggy
or the neck is too baggy or something
there's always like something that's not
exciting
short t-shirts you're talking about they
probably look better on you than the
ones that you that you that you prefer
well no i'm just got a weird taste on
our own self you know i mean like no i
don't yeah sometimes you do you say this
doesn't fit right i'm looking at it and
i'm going i don't know if it's
well no i'm saying that sometimes when i
say it doesn't fit right i mean it
doesn't feel comfortable like it feels
really so like if i go out in it i'm
always like
like it feels funny
because you're not used to wearing [ __ ]
that's no it's because it's
uncomfortable it's because it's she
looks really good and it's in skirts and
short skirts i can't get her to wear one
she's called i don't know i don't know i
can wear this short skirt she's got no
legs i don't like them she's i don't i'm
afraid if i pinned over anything will
just pop out and i'm going yeah of
course just don't yeah but i don't don't
do that right but what if i drop
something or whatever like i said i
haven't let like a lady in [ __ ] just
bouncing no because i have a lot of
feels to [ __ ] i'm 50 years old and he
says learn to be like a lady i've been
i've been a girl my whole life yeah well
don't just [ __ ] bend over and [ __ ]
you know i'm just saying everybody no
i'm just saying that like sometimes you
have to have like practical concerns
especially if
i'm like going out it's like i have to
be like well can i go to the bathroom in
this can i just you know can i dance in
this listen can i all this
i can understand what you're saying but
we're talking about going out to goth
clubs where about one-third of those
girls are [ __ ] damn near nude
right you're worried about it i'm not
worried about it i just don't want to do
that and it's like i and it's really
annoying that you like keep wanting me
to do it because i don't want to do it
yeah yeah you know what i mean
eventually this is going to happen
what it's eventually going to happen
no it's not because i don't want to do
it okay i don't know why you keep
thinking that like if you just keep
bugging me that like
just i don't want to do it and i don't
have to have a reason i just don't want
to do it you need to be in the miniskirt
i don't want to do it i've told you a
million times i don't want to do it it's
just not my thing it's not my thing okay
it's just not
uh american military hundred says
yelling i'm not yelling every time i say
yeah you say uh you're you're yelling
someone's bursting my eardrums when you
do it
you're getting loud
well whose fault is that that's that's
that crap you're giving me yeah
made my voice change i don't like that
american military 100 says jenny thank
you thank you thank you for recommending
bloody hell you're very welcome wasn't
that [ __ ] movie awesome i loved that
movie so much watched it last night one
of the most entertaining films i've seen
in years right and it's like i it's
weird because i hadn't heard anything
about it like usually if there's some
like big i mean i know it's not that new
like because it was from 2020 or 2021
but usually i'll hear some kind of buzz
like i'll see you know like a lot of
horror channels covering it or something
like that but that one i didn't really
see anything about it i only noticed it
because it popped up on shutter and it
had five skulls and i was like whoa
hang on a minute hardly anything gets
five skulls on shutter i think the only
things i can think of that are on there
right now that have five skulls are like
older [ __ ] like escape from new york
that has five skulls obviously like
stuff like that like classics um some
new ones hardly ever ever get that so i
was like well this must be like [ __ ]
amazing and so i watched it and i was
like man that was one of the funnest
things i've seen in a long time it's
really really good
um
danny rowling says uh i hear those
old-school belly shirts that athletes
used to wear back in the 80s that look
is coming back
oh my god
i remember that i remember like kind of
jocks and stuff like that wearing like
half shirts yeah half shirts which is
like hilarious it's hilarious yeah you
couldn't wear that [ __ ] unless you had a
[ __ ] six pack though
well i mean you can but
[Laughter]
david parker said what's up david
there's a lot of things you can do yeah
but but should you that's another yeah
you're not supposed to be wearing those
unless you got a [ __ ] stick
ah
yeah what's up dave
i imagine you're probably going to
mannequins this evening
yeah
dave says that i just tuned in that's
some bad hat tom i love it thank you
very much
just i got is it a bad hat or a badass
hat
i got two uh that's just a uh
that's a us army
[ __ ] bony cap it's just the black one
i got the it's not your sexual terrain
not my sexual transfer yeah my old army
unit in vietnam wore um tiger stripe so
i feel like i'm authorized to wear tiger
stripe as if that is my uniform but it
doesn't look as good on camera it
doesn't match with black but i got tiger
stripes stuff uh you know i still got a
lot of tiger striped uniforms and [ __ ]
but
you know it was never issued to us i i
would i didn't deploy vietnam
but uh my unit wore it which was a
vietnamese pattern
yeah it was a little before your time
yeah
a little
yeah a lot of that [ __ ] happened because
uh with the tiger stripe because a lot
of it was happening before the united
army was supposed to be there
so they were wearing south korean
uniforms and foreign uniforms pretending
to be mercenaries but they weren't they
were us army
that's why they were wearing it oscar
said i got a six-pack of beer yeah you
know
uh guamocon says the other day my
friends and i were watching sleepaway
camp and were in awe of all the fashions
yeah i don't think we've uh covered that
movie yet have we that's a that's an 80s
classic right there i mean it's
kind of terrible but it's also kind of
awesome at the same time
just kind of like oh the movie that we
saw at riptrax live last night was
actually
returned it was return of swamp thing
right with heather locklear
and i think that i had seen that
on cable like back but i had man i had
forgotten how
how [ __ ] terrible that movie was
it's so bad although tom was like i kind
of wish the movie had been worse
yeah like it was it wasn't as bad as
i mean it's bad but it wasn't as bad as
i mean he still think like the the kind
of like platonic ideal yeah of
the rift tracks movie or the riptrax
experience was like burdemic yeah
because that movie is not only awful
but there's also a lot of just baffling
creative decisions and like i said it
seems like it was made by somebody that
doesn't know how humans work yeah and so
a lot of the humor like comes from that
like of them just like reacting like
what the [ __ ] would they was he possibly
think
and oh and the other one that i wanted
to remember was the dude who thinks he's
a god
oh yeah that dude yeah yeah yeah um
we were just talking about him
oh my god his name just totally uh
did somebody else somebody will think of
it they got people that collect his
movies i know neil neil breen neil breen
brian neil breen
they got people that have all of his
movies and whenever he comes out of the
movie they get them
and i don't understand how you could sit
through that [ __ ] but we sat through
that was one i was think trying to think
of in the car oh okay uh [ __ ] neil
brain neil brain well we haven't seen
any i've seen like some uh i don't think
i've seen any roof tracks of any neil
breen movies i've seen like he talked
about um
the guy shitkay cinema talks about him a
lot maybe that's what it was so i've
seen like a bunch of his movies on
christmas checks did it or or um
mst one of the two
i know msc hasn't done any neoprene
rifftrax live but i think we saw
rifftrax on maybe because honestly
there's a [ __ ] ton
maybe i was left the thing about it like
to be has a [ __ ] ton if you're real into
mst or rifftrax or anything like um 2b
has a [ __ ] ton of episodes on there like
a a lot
and so i've been like slowly sort of
like working my way through them so it's
entirely possible for msd rifftrax well
they have mst on there too but the mscs
i mean those are all old like they have
all the old ones because the new ones
are with jonah ray and everything yeah
and those are on the gizmoplex now they
have their own site they have their own
streaming service neil brain's a genius
he's like a stupid genius yeah i mean
it's a it's almost kind of like you know
how like genius and stupid is kind of
like a circle like that and then you go
all the way around like
from genius and then like it's genius
and stupid right at this point or like
really really close it's kind of like a
normal person couldn't make a movie like
that
yeah obviously a normal person could not
make a movie like that yeah only someone
with some mental issues yeah
only a person who wanted to be seen in a
certain light and has fantasies about
himself can make a movie like that each
one of those movies is basically
a [ __ ] [ __ ] vanity project of a
man making a movie about
an idealized version of himself
but it's actually who he thinks other
people should see him as yeah they
should see him as a superior alien that
can fix all these [ __ ] problems and
can give free energy to man and stop the
earth from getting too hot and all that
everything he can even he can charm any
kind of woman doesn't matter what he
looks like he still can [ __ ] because
he just to me he looks like a stork or
something looks like big bird
there's something about the guy
and he's we'll hire them he's not ugly
but he's not like all that good looking
yeah he's just kind of like you like you
wouldn't you wouldn't give him a second
no
but he's just
that's not how he sees himself though
you know what i mean and
you can watch this movie and kind of
revert his movies and reverse engineer
them
and and pick him apart by like
dissect his mental health yeah
by what he's fantasizing about
and there's no sense of humor in the
[ __ ]
really that's what i mean he's serious
that's what makes them funny he's
serious that's what makes the funny
we've talked about that before that's
why it's so difficult
to
purposely make a so bad it's good movie
yeah because part of the thing that
makes those movies so funny is that
they're absolutely meant to be taken
seriously the person that made them
thought they were making a good movie
and didn't realize how everybody else
would that's why birdemic is like
[ __ ] hilarious because that guy
is just a really really weird [ __ ]
guy who doesn't know how people work and
doesn't know how movies work and doesn't
know what anything works but he seems
like a nice man he's just like really
really
clueless about like everything and he
just has really weird ideas about you i
think he would just be kind of mundane
in any culture but i think part of it is
that he's very he's of eastern origin
you know i mean he he's asian
and it's an asian guy who doesn't really
understand western culture that much so
he's trying to give western culture back
to westerners but it's only through the
lens of an eastern guy
like his idea of dating
and how white guys meet white women is
that you see her walking down the street
so you follow her home
and knock on her door
and then ask to come in you're gonna get
shot you do that
okay that's not and then or at least get
the police called on you at the very
least
[Laughter]
out in these areas you could get shots
yeah i mean unless you'll or at least
get maced yeah you know what i mean it's
not gonna be a good situation somebody's
gonna please don't do that what you
doing because they're just gonna think
the [ __ ] worst you know and then once
you're dating a girl
what she does is she sits on your lap
and straddles you face to face that's
that's what dating is
you remember that what a weird scene
that was that was i don't know every
time they showed them she's sitting
cross-legged yeah straddling it that's
what dating was every and and that must
be his fetish that must be his thing i
think he saw that he like or either that
or he really likes being straddled by
ladies and gentlemen extrapolating that
to everyone else like oh everyone else
must like this too well having lived in
korea you know which is similar in many
respects
vietnamese vietnamese i think he's
vietnamese i'm telling you they don't do
that in vietnam is that they never they
you would never see that kind of
interaction in public they just would
not see that they won't even hold hands
in public
so what stuck in his mind was the fact
that one that
a young
white women sit
and
straddle young guys
in public he's like ooh i like that yeah
he lied about that that's every time
okay get on his lap that's what you all
do you know i mean i saw it so y'all do
it you know
you guys are doing that all the time
it's just it's just weird it is very
weird yeah
you guys know like if you if you enjoyed
if that's the word uh burdemic he made
some other movies he made one called
replicas which was like a sci-fi movie
and it's pretty great like i watched the
rifftrax version which i think is still
on toby
and the entire thing
apparently he decided that a really good
way to make movies would be to shoot all
of these
actors and i use that term uh very
loosely in front of a green screen and
then he buys
stock footage environments and drops it
behind there yeah um so even something
as mundane as like an office or
something like that like he'll just kind
of like drop it behind there so none of
these people are like in the actual
environments that they're in and you can
tell well he's probably doing it in his
house that's what i'm saying i think he
probably yeah so i don't know like how
uh how cheap these movies are they seem
like they're really cheap so yeah he
made replicas and also he made one
called what was that one called it was
two people's names it was like jack and
julie or something like that and i think
riptrax did that one too
and it was almost like well it was like
a romance
but
there was wait there was death or
reincarnation or something like that i
can't really remember like what the
specific angle i think it was
reincarnation type thing but it was one
of the weirdest things i've ever seen
it's just so weird and the thing about
it like when we were at rifftrax live
last night
um apparently it's their 16th year like
their 16th anniversary so they had like
a little
it was really funny because they had
like this little video like ahead where
everyone was like hey going hey like you
know happy sweet 16 or whatever so like
weird al yankovic and all that kind of
like uh people on there like
congratulating them on being on for 15
years and one of the people that was on
there was that guy
who was what's his name james nyan right
like i said he seemed like he was you
know reading off his laptop or whatever
but i mean he seemed like a nice enough
man and he seemed to like understand
that
maybe they were making and they had some
other people on there too who had made
movies that had been on there
like i said maybe it's not like the old
days because i kind of feel like there
used to be a thing
where
if your movie was on mystery science
theater like some filmmakers would get
very offended because you know obviously
they're making fun of your movie
but i think like as time went on and it
became
maybe not mainstream popular but it kind
of became like a cultural thing
so now i kind of feel like maybe
sometimes people are making movies bad
enough that they hope will turn up on
there because like they'll you'll get
more traction that way more people are
going to see your movie if it's on
rifftrax then would just like find it
it's hard to pass that test that's what
i'm saying because like i said before
neil breen is neil is his name i think
it's neil breen yeah brain
i know that's the last name but i think
it's neil breen
you can't make a movie like that unless
you got issues okay
i could come up with a i love me movie
make a movie about myself me loving
myself and how awesome i am but it would
be hilarious because i'm gonna [ __ ]
go overboard
okay well yeah and it's gonna it's it's
gonna be hard for me to take that
project seriously okay that's what i'm
saying it's that's the thing like you
he's taking this [ __ ] right seriously
all right he's always some kind of
savior figure and he's and he's not
playing as straight
he's [ __ ] straight
yeah i mean he's not pretending to play
it straight he's playing he's straight
yeah he's very which is very which is a
very like fine line distinction but it
is a distinction and yeah these movies
are supposed to be educational
kind of like documentaries
all right
and you're supposed to remember him you
know you're supposed to associate these
you're supposed to associate all the uh
the the qualities of this character with
him with neal
neal is the creator of all this okay
and
he's
as far as he's concerned he's a great
writer great director and that these are
movies that are changing the world okay
is it this is [ __ ] bono level
that's what i was thinking it was like
well you know what but the thing about
it is that bono was actually like
talented yeah yeah youtube was actually
like a good band and he's a good singer
imagine if bono was in a band that
[ __ ] sucked
okay
like sub anvils
yeah suckage right
but he thought he was
god's gift to the [ __ ] world
and he genuinely did think that and
thought that his whole mission in life
was to inform everyone else all the
other ignorant people of the human race
of that fact that's kind of the vibe
that i'm getting there
he's kind of like the movie director
version of this russian kid i forgot his
name but he would go around on
and online and brag about what a badass
[ __ ] fighter he was like he's the
[ __ ] ultimate fighter and this you
know all the championships he won and
he's making these belts himself he's
giving himself his own belts
and uh is he making them out of like
construction paper and crayons because
that would be awesome yeah
he's just making amount of stuff that he
finds you know
and then he's challenging other people
to fight him and when he shows up
he has other people record him and he
just for a regular sparring match and
then he [ __ ] goes after the dude
tries to knock him out because he's
trying to get video of himself knocking
somebody out
but but then if a real fighter show up
he runs he talks a lot of [ __ ] but then
they start swinging on him and he he
runs he can't he can't he can't fight
but he's like that he's kind of like a
direct movie director that i got i
remember that guy's name he's a russian
and his mom came down and tried to stop
one of the fights one time
because yeah badass
his mom came down trying to stop one of
the fights one time his mom and his
stepdad because he's got um
he's got some mental problems he's got
some kind of obvious yeah he's he's got
some kind of schizophrenia or something
or so he's delusional he's delusional
yeah
but he thinks he's a famous world famous
ufc fighter
but see that's the thing it almost comes
to a point where
yeah you want to make fun of them after
but after a certain point you can't
really make fun of them because anybody
that's that
far gone it probably has some pretty
severe yeah mental issues and you don't
really want to make fun of them because
they probably can't help it yeah you
know what i mean so it's just kind of
like because i i mean i've met a lot of
people in my 50 years and uh you know
they have varying degrees of
self-awareness
uh some people are not really all that
self-aware but usually if you meet
somebody that has absolutely zero
self-awareness and they just think
they're the most awesome thing ever and
you can't convince them otherwise then
usually that's somebody that has some
pretty severe mental issues zachary just
keeps trying to get us to do carry okay
we'll do we haven't done carrie i guess
not um i thought we had done it hand me
that yeah we got like i got some shout
outs to you let me do it before we get
like too far into this
like okay
now for one thing we have our first new
patron in a very long time oh [ __ ] man i
forgot about patience
you never get any goddamn patrons i mean
we still have all of our all of our like
normal ones
but it's like we haven't got a new one
and we don't have that many i think we
got 10 patrons no we have like 30 or oh
yeah
yeah okay so um i mean that's not we had
a lot we had some more we
we had a lot more like in the old days
back in the old days maybe we've lost
like some people yeah [ __ ] pandemic
got a lot of them
well yeah well it started happening like
kind of after that but yeah um so but we
did get a new one just earlier today
actually named chris so hi chris if
you're out there thank you very much uh
for joining we also
um you know we talked about the camp
guys shirts right and i'm gonna mail
those out tomorrow
um
also i wanted to give a thank you to
dermot one of our uk listeners who sent
me an amazon gift card because he wanted
to hear our take on the
remake like the salem's lot mini series
from the 2000s he's like it's actually
pretty good i haven't seen it yeah so he
so he sent me a um a gift card so we
could buy it and watch it so we're gonna
do that so thank you very much dermot
and
zaneta
sent us because we were talking about
this i guess on wednesday or the other
day we were talking about this uh so
xanada sent us this right here to
blu-ray of yeah no country for old men
that's my boy zanna to the desert fox
best picture yeah yeah he lives out in
the desert he's moved out there he's
lived he's lived in a couple of
different places i helped him with some
ar 15 builds and everything and that's
his favorite movies man you guys see
this movie and i saw it but i i didn't
really pay that much attention to it
because oh you guys see it again man
you'd like you should you should i've
seen it like two or three times and it's
really really good right it's an awesome
movie i mean we would we do suggestions
but if you send us the movie it moves to
the front of the [ __ ] line
this is only one movie okay so i'm gonna
move this to the front of the line we'll
we'll do this one we'll watch it
tomorrow night we'll talk about it
sunday we've got to get on [ __ ] um
godfather got on father two and three
yeah and i think that's the only thing
outstanding
because we eventually got around to
collateral that was another one that
hernandez wanted me to watch was like i
said we're gonna die like goddamn park
that was a great movie we're going to
have to do uh the salem's live thing
which actually i'm kind of curious to
see it because
you know it's a mini series huh also i
think dermot sent me some money too to
do to see uh behind the candelabra which
was the michael douglas movie about
liberace okay so we're gonna have to do
that too i wrote it down somewhere all
right
so what we'll do is we'll watch that one
and then we'll watch um godfather two
and we'll do that and then we'll get on
salem's lot and then we'll do candelabra
yeah
i mean like i said i'm trying to keep
track of everything like we have like a
lot of movies and i'm trying to think if
there's anything else that was
pressing
i think that's the only thing that was
in line
i think so like we'll look through our
stuff again but yeah i'm pretty sure
because i try to write things down like
sometimes i forgot but
so if you told me like some [ __ ] before
and i forgot then i know somebody
recommended um just for me to do like on
my flickers of fear show like the norlis
tapes yeah and i'm gonna do that um
it'll be up the 25th
because i saw that you could watch it
for free so i'm gonna watch that and do
that but oh and somebody told me
to do um the boris karloff like uh
horror anthology the thriller series and
i'm gonna start
doing that on my scare salon channel but
i have to do i didn't realize that there
were
uh a bunch of seasons
that are like 10 episodes each so i was
like oh my god this is like 10 hours
worth of content so i'm just gonna do
like one season every now and then so
sometime this month uh i'll do thriller
season one samantha says the sale is
rotten the salem's lot remake is coming
out in that on the 23rd
store okay yeah i thought i'd heard
about that let's see how they handle it
salem's lot was a great movie i liked
the old the original television series
maybe this one's going to be good too
they say it's good so we'll we'll see
um let me see
uh zach is guava [ __ ] said you guys
mentioned liberace in uh the misery
review yeah we mentioned liberty
he mentions liberace like all the time
not all the time but on several simple
occasions i usually will mention
liberace if i ever fall on the subject
of um even knievel who was a childhood
hero of mine most boys my age growing up
in their in the 70s [ __ ] um
love [ __ ] evil knievel and that was
just and
modern people do not understand what
evil knievel was
and is
to ex-generation
boys
it was a multimedia
[ __ ]
phenomena at the time he was on
television and he was doing live [ __ ]
stunts
and it was a dude that was basically
trying to kill himself in front of a
live audience so he everybody's like
yeah we'd like to see more of that
please they were paying to see him kill
himself and he it was not staged in any
way
almost no safety involved he wasn't even
wearing body armor
and there's all kinds of slow-motion
films
and [ __ ] wide world of sports made
him [ __ ] famous in the intro of wide
world to sports in the background is a
slow-motion [ __ ]
shot of evil knievel rolling across the
asphalt in slow motion as he's breaking
basically every bone in his body
from a wide world of sports
i don't know if you guys remember that
man as a kid i would watch the beginning
of the wide world of sports just to see
evil just being crumpled up in slow
motion it was [ __ ] wild um
he was he was a madman
yeah clearly
just a mean old [ __ ] redneck and he
was [ __ ] psychopathic and [ __ ] uh
uh he was awesome at the same time uh
very heroic
he his job was to attempt to kill
himself in front of a live audience to
make a bunch of money so he could live
the high life and [ __ ]
afford to
afford a big lifestyle for him and his
wife and his kids and his girlfriends he
had girlfriends too you know he was just
a southern
[ __ ] insane
wild man that had no skills other than
he could
basically jump a motorcycle that was
never meant to be jumped
and he had fear he would talk about it
but he would just conquer it
well his hero was liberace
the one of the most alpha
testosterone-filled
[ __ ]
macho [ __ ]
tight [ __ ] in the world just so
i can love liberace right
and liberace was a dude on a toll on the
uh totally other end of the spectrum
you know and for some reason
even knievel thought that that dude was
the bravest [ __ ] man in the world you
know well at the time he probably was
yeah
i think it was also even knievel [ __ ]
experience in escapism
it's like you know he was fantasizing
that he could be a man like that
who just made money with his fingers
safely
behind a piano
and just ran the show
and had no
he didn't have to kill himself in front
of an audience i think that's part of it
you know what i mean
he had no family responsibilities he
wasn't he didn't have a wife or a kid
and
didn't have to worry about a
heterosexual sex drive or anything you
know he was just the total opposite
so i kind of think that
from
evil's point of view is that he was
seeing a man who was free i think that's
what he what he saw well and the thing
about liberace too and like i said you
have to think that you know at the time
that he was famous
uh you know yeah everybody knew he was
gay but it wasn't really like all that
acceptable so
the fact that he just came out and
wasn't real secretive about it and he
was just kind of like yeah but he was
still like commanding audiences
and everyone was like so i can see how
that would be really appealing to
somebody who maybe maybe evel knievel
had some kind of thing where he felt
like he couldn't be himself in some way
or another and so he admired that in
somebody else maybe that's what he
thought well if you look at evil
knievel's um
when you hear him tell a story he felt
that he was being commanded by the
audience and that the author that's what
i was going to say the audience was
trying to kill him yeah because paying
to see him and i mean that's pretty
perceptive because
yes that's absolutely why people were
coming were watching him they were i
don't want to say people were like legit
hoping that he would die because like i
said if he died they'd probably feel
really bad yeah but
it's just kind of like anything i mean
why do people watch nascar why did
people watch evil knievel why do people
like they kind of want to see wrecks and
injuries and stuff like that it's [ __ ]
up but it's true that's why people
largely watch that kind of stuff
so
he was very um insightful and he was
just like yeah they just want to see me
get [ __ ] up yeah because they did
there's good there's uh some good um
shows about him on uh on youtube you can
find them they were made by the history
channel i think both of them one of them
was called being evil
and um
it's about e-v-e-l being evil
and uh they're if you've never seen them
you should see them they're good and he
tells stories and tells his story
eva knievel was very intelligent he
wasn't educated but he was very
intelligent uh and he found a way where
he could make fame and fortune he
considered himself to be a modern
gladiator where
a dude who's willing to kill himself in
front of a bunch of people
but he felt like the crowd was
paying to see him possibly paying to see
him die
we'll see now that's kind of going back
to um what we were talking about a
little bit on the misery review where a
lot of times if you get that famous
particularly for doing something like
that which is like actually bodily
harmful um
you it can kind of become a double-edged
sword because you're kind of
you know your audience kind of wants you
to get [ __ ] up you don't really want
to get [ __ ] up but you don't want to
like let them down either
because if you just keep doing stuff
like all cool and don't like break any
bones or something like people are
probably gonna tripped away and not want
to see it yeah so you can kind of feel
like well you have to keep upping the
stakes like because everyone's gonna
stop caring yeah so i get so it's almost
kind of like like i said we were talking
about the misery review like a little
bit like toxic fandom yeah he lived in
toxic fandom yeah he got famous
for that um caesar's palace jump and
that was the opening shots in [ __ ]
wide world of sports it got drilled into
people's head him being slowly crumpling
up in a roll just breaking pretty much
every bone in his body yeah he did and
and that was a failed job but it was
success market-wise because everybody
knew that it was real yeah that this
dude was for real and that's what his
whole [ __ ]
fandom was based on this dude is
gonna try to kill himself let's go see
it he's crazy he's a bad [ __ ]
he's a bad he was and he was a a really
cool dude he incorporated liberace and
elvis into his act those were his two
[ __ ] heroes
nobody did what he did he was a
evil was a [ __ ] one of a kind he
tells a bunch of stories about what he
did with people's wives and [ __ ] while
he was on tour
there was all kinds of weird [ __ ] you
know he was cucking out and then he had
security around him all the time because
he would say crazy [ __ ]
and people would try to beat his ass so
the security was constantly trying to
keep him from getting his ass well
that's another thing too you go around
that was huge you make your whole living
out of being a badass yeah then there's
always going to be people that are oh my
god
i'm going to beat this badasses yeah you
know ass
big dude he was just fearless
fear
well no he wasn't fearless
he had fear he was just uh he was able
to control this fear very well i ride
bikes
i would never take a [ __ ] harley
sportster and and [ __ ] try to
catch as much air as he was doing on
basically a stock harley sportster
they've been stripped out of nothing
jumping all those [ __ ] buses and
[ __ ] cars and [ __ ] and those bikes
were only good for one jump he cracked
the frame on the way down and
that bike was never meant to be in the
air
that was a [ __ ] basically a sport
bike of its time just [ __ ] crazy
he was crazy
but he didn't know what he was doing it
was all kind of mathematically thought
out
yeah yeah he was crazy but he wasn't bad
but not crazy
yeah
uh rebecca says netflix australia
finally released high plains drifter
this past wednesday night oh my god is
brilliant yeah genuine supernatural
revenge western yeah that's easily but
this is probably
my favorite who said that rebecca
rebecca yeah that was probably my
favorite that was the original crow
yeah basically yeah it's about like a
revenant yeah which is yeah it's super
cool i really really like that movie a
lot
uh zach says i think the best i'm kind
of behind on the comments so forgive me
if you commented a long time ago and you
guys have like moved on to other topics
but i'm trying to like catch up uh i
think the best horror movies says zach
are ones that are genuinely emotional
and drama like uh carrie and hereditary
for example yeah i agree i usually i
mean i don't know it kind of depends on
my mood because i like all kinds of
different horror
um like i said i'm very willing to just
be like hey what do you got uh you know
whatever you want to show me it's that's
fine
but
most of the movies that i tend to like
the most are ones that have like a lot
um have like an emotional core of like
the characters and stuff like that and i
think oscar said earlier that like uh
hereditary was like the second greatest
uh horror movie at like after the
exorcist yeah i don't know if i'd rank
it quite that high but honestly like
hereditary was i mean that [ __ ] blew
my [ __ ] socks off like when i saw it
in 2018 and i've seen it a couple times
since then and man
that
that made me that movie made me like i
know this is a weird thing to say but
that movie made me so happy like the
first time i saw it because i was like
that movie scared the absolute [ __ ] out
of me and that had not happened like
since i was a kid you know what i mean
it gave me like literal like legitimate
nightmares like after i saw that movie
and i know that it's not the same for
everybody but like i said that's the
thing about horror everybody likes
different [ __ ] scares different people
but that movie like that that [ __ ]
got me that got me
ian england said uh my favorite horror
flick is event horizon that is a good
one yeah
uh a little bit underrated i feel like
maybe that one we talked about that when
we reviewed that one right you got a
super chat did we okay yeah i'm super
fine uh thank you thank you thank you
ian england happy friday very much happy
friday to you thank you
flashballs
you hit him in this like light that
comes up it's like flash balls from
airplane is that what you're seeing them
flash bulbs you know the two black guys
at the airport
yeah yeah that's right from airplane
yeah and they're taking a picture so
because let's let me see them flash
bulbs that's right yeah that's where you
got it from yeah
what do you say sebastian moran said the
norlis tapes i'm gonna do that on i
think it's gonna go up on the 25th
i'm actually gonna watch it this weekend
and i'll do a review of it
john gore said hereditary definitely put
me in a weird space for the next
following days yeah me too and like i
said that hadn't happened for like a
really long time i think the last time
that it happened
was
when i was a kid and i saw the shining
for the first time and it like [ __ ]
weirded me out like because that movie
particularly like the old lady in the
bathtub like that scared the [ __ ] i know
when i was a kid but rolling ghost faces
asking me about it
about an 87 ninja i can answer that okay
with expertness right read it out what
does it say it says uh tom what's your
opinion on a 1987 kawasaki ninja for a
first bike okay i owned the 1988 which
is exactly like it but which which one
are you talking about the 600 the 750 or
the 1000 there's a big difference
i had the 600
okay
and uh
that was my first 600.
i got that in uh
1991.
that's a dangerous motorcycle okay
um
but it may be in the bathroom but it
made me a very good rider
it's basically a norton featherbed frame
with a liquid cooled
parallel 4 600 cc engine in it
it's like an old school motorcycle
with a kind of overpowered motor for
what it was
i mean that frame
and chassis wasn't too far away from the
1970s in terms of performance
that bike was about limitations i mean
you could feel everything
you could feel the back end [ __ ]
breaking out you could you could ride it
like a [ __ ] demon
but once you got to that edge and
crossed over you could wipe that bike
out that's the bike that was riding that
[ __ ] got my [ __ ] frontal head
injury
although
i actually got hit by a car but i was
[ __ ] speeding that [ __ ] [ __ ]
would go fast all right for the day not
by today's standards but
the 1000s in the [ __ ] 750s were even
hotter
uh it depends on you man depends on what
kind of person you are all right
there are no modern rider aids in that
the suspension was [ __ ] like a pogo
the brakes were not all that good
uh
you felt everything
coming off that bike and going into
other bikes other bikes that were much
faster felt [ __ ]
so easy to ride compared to that one
okay
because a
newer more modern bikes really kind of
shields you from a lot of stuff
and you can kind of find you kind of
know where the performance edges on a
more modern edge is on a more modern
bike
that one you wouldn't know where the
edge was until you crossed it
okay
so as a first bike
depends on who you are um
in general i'd say no
no that's a widow maker
especially if you don't have any
discipline
and also depends if uh how old you are
if you're young you won't have the
[ __ ] be able to resist the temptation
and you'll [ __ ]
you kill yourself you'll kill yourself
if you're old you don't really have the
[ __ ]
you don't really have the synapses and
the [ __ ] muscle memory and the
experience
that you need to survive that bike
that's a bike you have to go on at about
[ __ ] 20
and make a bunch of mistakes on
and ride it for three or four years
and wreck it okay
and then go on into another bike and all
of a sudden other bikes seem really easy
compared to that one
now the 1000 was a little bit different
the 1000 was a little it was a lot
faster but it had better stuff on it it
could deal with it it was bigger
not quite as nimble not quite as radical
it was a little more uh
uh what do you what the [ __ ] shut up
i tell that thing not to bother me
but so i don't know what did he ever
answer is it the 600 is everything 750
the 750.
the 750 was only a little bit bigger
than the 700 than the 600 but it had
more power
it was heavier
it had better brakes and suspension if i
remember correctly though
had some anti-dive features that i'm not
really sure they actually worked
really bikes from the late 80s you need
to leave those alone okay
those are widow makers by today's
standards they made more power than
really they should have
and they were on kind of narrow wheels
and you can't really get really good
rubber for those
and they're old now so there's going to
be a lot of problems they weren't fuel
injected they were carbureted
don't [ __ ] with that man get something
that's a little more modern
for a first bike i'd recommend a twin a
two cylinder not a force holder
it's something like an sv 650 or
i think it's now i think it's now a 700
or an 800 or something get a two
cylinder motorcycle
liquid cooled
something mid 4 or 1000
v twin something that's a little
narrower and easier to deal with they're
faster on the street because it's more
torque you know
someone say about it okay uh holy parish
of doom yeah um
they were talking about hereditary uh i
was glad to be out in the sunny parking
lot after hereditary yeah that movie
that [ __ ] me up i didn't like it the
first time i saw it i fell asleep and
the second time i liked it a lot better
there is so much going on in that
[ __ ] movie and the thing about that
movie it's one of those movies that and
i very very rarely get this and look i
love horror i read horror novels i watch
horror movies i read about real horror
because like murders and serial killers
and [ __ ] like that pretty much every day
that movie really really got to me it
really made me the whole time i was
watching it
it made me
feel like like my stomach was just like
clenched like a fist i shoot and i don't
usually get that like the last time i
had that happen i think was the movie
the invitation from 2016
um which if you haven't seen it is
[ __ ] excellent it's actually more
i want to say it's more a thriller but
it's all it's kind of like a horror
movie too that movie like i was just
like that like the whole time like oh
crap oh crap oh crap and like hereditary
was like that too but hereditary
legitimately gave me nightmares for like
a week or two afterward that movie like
[ __ ] me up a lot and i know that it
doesn't have that effect on everybody
yeah but i've read a lot of other
reviews that had this same exact
reaction to it as i did and if you watch
it more than once
you pick up
[ __ ] tons of stuff that's in there oh my
god there's like so much foreshadowing
there's so much [ __ ] going on in the
background and in the margins of the
shots and everything like that it's
[ __ ] brilliant look if you set on
expert i understand why she likes that
movie okay it's it's good
if you're set on expert you'll you'll
appreciate it but if you're more like me
which i'm more of a general audience
you're probably mid-summer better it's
the same director same [ __ ] company i
like mid-summer a lot better i mean
mid-summer is also amazing yeah i love
mid-south yeah mid-summer was kind of
like wicker man
uh but i love it and i'm and i'm into
folk horror too so yeah i really liked
it and they're well they're in the same
universe they're like it's cool about re
aster
is that
i know you haven't seen the witch yet
you might i don't i don't i don't know
if you would like the witch or not
i can't
you might love it you might hate it i'm
not sure i loved it but
it's kind of one of those things that
you either love it or hate it you know
what i mean um you know it's set in
you know which times like 16 1700's and
it's
in that language you know what i mean so
i don't know if you like it or not and
it's but it's super super creepy
so
i don't know but the thing about it is
that ari astor it's like he makes these
movies and they're
on their surface are like completely
different movies i mean mid-summer
and hereditary are completely different
and yet
i don't know like there's still kind of
like a thematic
element that he's kind of like i don't
know i think that dude is like he's
probably like the best easily i think
the best horror filmmaker working today
for sure
like he always makes something like
really really interesting
and
i was just like i said i was so happy
when i saw hereditary because i said man
it has been a long time i said i think
the last time i was that
[ __ ] traumatized by a movie
was when i saw the shining for the first
time yeah and that was when i was a kid
like a little kid like i was probably
like 11 or something and it [ __ ]
stressed me out and i hadn't felt that
since then well okay that's a lie
i think when they did um you know gore
verbinski's remake of the ring
that freaked me out not as bad as
hereditary
but that freaked me out and the weird
thing about it is that like i saw the
american remake
of
the ring because obviously it's a
japanese film started out and i saw the
japanese one later ring you
and
it was good but it wasn't the same like
it didn't stress me out as much as the
first one did man that first one's like
stressed me out i think i saw that in
the theater too and i was just kind of
like and i think i had nightmares like
for a couple days after that one too but
not as bad as hereditary hereditary
[ __ ] me up and like i said i get it
like if you didn't feel that way too but
i do kind of feel like there is
a pretty like
i've read like a lot of other comments
and people that reacted to it the same
way that i reacted to it it [ __ ]
stressed me out that [ __ ] movie it
stressed me out so
i mean
just like [ __ ] props to arie astra
you he [ __ ] got me
and
horror movies have not got me for like a
very very long time and that one that
one did okay lane england says you can
get a newer ninja used for like 2 500
and they come with all the new riders
yeah that that's what you want to do you
can there's so many newer bikes out
there that are used that are so much
better than that old ninja okay that old
ninja i'd ride it but i'm an expert
rider and i know the limitations of that
generation i came up on those
but that's not
a modern bike and
for a new rider those were unforgiving
man those were never designed for new
riders they designed those for guys that
had come up on bikes from the 70s and
then lars comes in and says i don't ride
but i love i could buy any bike from the
1970s and my response is no you couldn't
no you couldn't
all those 70s bikes are gone they're all
in the hands of guys that know what they
are they're restored or their
collector's items uh you can't find a
70s bike not around here
and uh
florida is motorcycle heaven
it's all here
anything 70s is in the hands of somebody
who knows what they have and they're
worth a lot of money okay
it's not like it's not like it was back
in the early 90s where you could find a
70s bike just sitting there [ __ ]
rotten
you know what i mean and buy it for a
couple hundred or a thousand dollars
those days are over
um
pretty much every 70s motorcycle is in
the hands of some collector around here
you can just well the thing about
florida there's a lot of bikers that
live here and it's
it's a good riding place because it's
flat and there's like a lot of like
country roads like twisting country
roads yes even a novice rider can pick
up a lot of speed and do a lot of [ __ ]
yeah um let me see hold on uh slasher
friend said wicker man is like a pre get
out it is kind of it's it's kind of
similar if you like wicker man you like
you'd love mid-summer you'd understand
exactly you haven't seen get out though
but yeah that was uh the same guy that
made nope and us and yeah buy you
another drink let me buy you another one
you're gonna buy me another drink okay
um
thank you very much
guamo what is it guang khan or guamo
kun
i'm sure i'm pronouncing it wrong i'm
like really bad with that um always a
pleasure dropping by these shows and
still glad to see y'all going strong and
giving us quality content oh that's
that's so nice thank you very much we
have a lot of fun especially these
friday night shows these are like my
favorite things i actually really look
forward to doing these um i look forward
to all of the shows but
uh you know the other shows and i've
said this before a little bit more
stressful because i actually like have
to do research beforehand and like make
sure i'm getting like all the
all the all the facts in there that need
to get in there because i'm you know
kind of anal retentive like that so
it's kind of cool to just you know have
a drink and hang out with you guys and
not worry about notes and stuff michael
shafer said anybody remember the movie
life force yes that's actually quite a
rad movie uh it's tobey hooper in case
you didn't know i think he came out at
85 right and um we actually did a review
of that not too long ago it's on shutter
right now if you want to watch it
but
uh it's another one that's kind of a
little bit underrated life force
yeah oh yeah i don't have it also like a
naked lady the whole time if you're into
that yeah beautiful beautiful naked cute
little skinny what was there matilda may
i think her name was yeah she didn't
speak any english
well she didn't talk in the movie she
didn't have to talk yeah she just walked
around she didn't have to talk she just
walked around naked and everybody's like
all right
she was cute
real cute not really my type i like a
little more meat i like big five
yeah
yeah
short with big fine i like you know kind
of a
peyton presley type if you guys knew
that is you you porn aficionados i'm
into that tom is a porn official i love
[ __ ] porn stars
[Laughter]
bill just like one
if y'all want to know what that looks
like [ __ ] when she's [ __ ]
running 100
angela white that's that's what she
looks like
i like that he's he he can like angela
white that's hilarious that he can cross
between angela angela white sophie d i
can put him all in a [ __ ] order
[Laughter]
he's a like i said he's a bubologist
he's also a pornographer biologist
pornology
i'm going to start putting that after
your name yeah yeah yeah
pornologist like phd
you should you know what you should do
you should start charging money to give
people like a phd in biology biology and
poor knowledge yeah yeah i mean you can
have like a little disclaimer the same
obviously no one's gonna like take this
seriously but you could like sell like
little certificates and
stuff started part of this [ __ ] started
when something when i heard the quote is
it's hard to define porn but you know
what it is when you see it yeah well
it's like yeah i think it was about
obscenity i think that was like
you know when you see it yeah then i
started to think well what is the
science behind this what is attractive
what's happening inside of a dude when
he's looking at these images you know
what i mean there is a science to it
it's all different but there's there's a
science to it now i don't have to go to
some university to do it i can just look
at the input and then judge and then
read the comments because i go to the
porn sites and read the comments
sometimes that's how you know you're
like really into porn when you go to
like a porn star and like you know
comment on the although i have to say
that the ones that i've seen like most
of the comments are just stupid yeah
like they're not like super like like
hot i'm like yeah okay yeah yeah that's
kind of the point of porn so well no you
want to go to ones where there's about
was about a hundred comments
because if there's a hundred you want to
see ones where they're in there like
actually like insightful about yeah well
no they're in there fighting and then
you can set up a cycle analyze why
they're fighting why they're fighting
and then uh okay it is actually pretty
interesting yeah see uh
coming out of
a military type background and [ __ ]
clubs
and you all know me for your regular i
go ahead and embrace the primal with
sex and violence those are these the
primal things inside of human beings
and it is healthy
it just has to be channeled the right
way
you are what you are because the animals
are what they are animals are exactly
the same way
so you want to know how people work and
me being
also involved with horses and you know
which are selectively bred
thoroughbred horses you know they're
they're animals too
and dealing with cats and [ __ ]
hunting animals like deer and this and
that
human and animal behavior is always
fascinating to me
it is like dealing with machines
partially
so i just like to know how things work
and why things work
and
once you know that you can't you can
game the system
because really there's a lot of
different kinds of genius in this world
you got musical geniuses you got [ __ ]
mathematical geniuses
geniuses of physics and [ __ ] like that
but they never talk about
genius of human engineering these are
people that
have a lot of charisma
and can achieve great things through
relationships and other people
and a lot of that has to do with just
the primal
forces between
sex and violence all right that's really
what it is you're talking about
sticks and carrots
and once you know that system
and it's part of you
which it has always been a part of me
um
you can do
great things or good things or bad
things depending on and a mixture of
them all
but it depends on who you are some
people
are aware of this and other people
aren't
roman history showed me a lot of this
the romans embraced all this
the idea of an alpha roman
with sticks and carrots
you support
the people you care about and your
family and your supporters and your
friends
but then you ruthlessly
prosecute
vengeance upon enemies and make them pay
this is a very gangster mentality like
just like the mob like the italian mob
they were using that same philosophy
and it's just fascinating you know and
that that's actually how the world works
at the highest levels
billionaires and people that [ __ ] run
governments and agencies outside of
governments they are just like that we
have to know
how these people work and how they think
and if you don't then you won't be able
to defend yourself and the people you
care about
i'm just going to leave at that
but i embrace this i don't reject it
i don't see anything wrong with this
this is the way it's supposed to be
everything is
everything is as it is because that's
what it's supposed to be
nothing is wrong
not really
if something wrong happens you can
always avenge it
or correct it
okay
and anything that can't survive in
nature
isn't true
you know
there are only there are very few truths
and the truth is very universal
and buddhism talks about this you know
it's not just me pulling this out of my
ass it's everything that i've learned
and [ __ ]
you learn it from
things that are ancient
i'm getting wasted
yeah i see that
guam is talking about get out being my
favorite of the three jordan peel movies
now i haven't seen nope yet uh people
see it's good and i do really want to
see it it's still playing we can go i
noticed uh when we went to see roof
tracks we didn't see we didn't see
[ __ ] we didn't see the new top gun we
didn't see top gunners we didn't see the
elvis movie we didn't see a lot of
things yeah um but you know we just
never go it's too far i mean it's really
far like i had to put [ __ ] money yeah
i had to put like a bunch of well i mean
last night we go we got to see two
movies
we probably should if we're going all
the way we're gonna go we're gonna see
two movies i can't believe
that the movie theater that was closest
to where we used to live is still the
movie theater that's closest to where we
live now even though
we moved it's 36 minutes okay it's 36
minutes to get there but there isn't a
closer one
um you know what i mean so what are you
gonna do uh yeah my favorite three
jordan peel movies yeah i mean get out
was amazing i really liked us as well we
saw that twice in the theater actually
but i haven't seen nope yet i've heard
it's awesome so i'm really excited about
seeing that now um thanks squadmilcom i
just saw that now yeah that was yes
that's what i asked earlier like how
they pronounced it but camp guy said
audition
is a freaky japanese horror movie one of
these days
i keep saying i'm gonna do that movie
but i don't know if i want to watch it
again yeah like to review it um
it's an awesome movie i'm not saying
that but man
it's just it's so [ __ ] up like toward
the end and i'm just like do i really
want to like subject myself to that
again i will eventually i will okay
danny danny says i like older bites you
don't see much anymore
anything older
the best thing i could recommend if it's
a little bit older is uh get a bull
some kind of older build that you can
find
because it's torque it's not a lot of
horsepower
most of the time the chassis
another a b will won't an older buell
will not kill you all right as long as
it's not on s1 all right that
gets something like that it's mellow but
a lot of stop light to stop light power
if you can find them bills are driving
drying up here now i got two of them
they're hard to find now here people are
buying them up
i'm looking for an s1
hard to find now though they only they
made i think 500 of them
i think it was around that okay that's
all i say slash your friend said one of
these days you should review the
original frankenweenie i have actually
been wanting to get around to doing that
uh because i actually uh like that quite
a bit they're talking about their
favorite porn stars uh zoe britton yeah
georgina spelvin i don't know that one
uh alison tyler
larkin love yeah larkin larkin is
actually a local she was up at the up
the uh castle all the time
oh yeah so we might just gotta check
yeah
uh
yeah
um let's see
schizophrenia the horror mangler the
weirdest movie you will ever watch i
don't know there's like a lot of
uh grampter says why do people still go
to nasty porn video places on the side
of the highway when there's free porn
everywhere hookers well
maybe some people just like that
experience i don't know what's going on
in their head but maybe there's
something maybe some people still find
it like impersonal
to
just like be able to access whatever
porn you want it's just kind of like
maybe how
people even though you can like um
you know digitally access any music you
want like some people just want to go to
the record store and get like the vinyl
you know what i mean so maybe it's the
equivalent it's like the hipster
equivalent
it's like a porn hipster that's what it
is
i you know what's weird i had a dream
last night
that i went that i was like in
like an old bookstore like that had old
books and records and stuff like that
and it was just kind of like
i don't even remember all that happened
in the dream but i was like looking i
was like ooh they had like all this
really cool [ __ ] like all this like
music that i liked and booked the books
that i liked and stuff and i was like oh
i'm gonna get all this stuff and just
like i don't know it was like a really
nice dream i didn't usually i have like
kind of shitty or boring dreams so it
was kind of nice having like kind of an
awesome dream where i was like oh like
the old days of like when you used to go
and hang out in bookstores all day long
i love that kind of [ __ ]
um let's see
slasher fred the channels hbo yeah hbo
max cinemax used to show some adult
programming during the 90s and early
2000s yeah they didn't call it skin and
max for nothing yeah it was softcore
porn i mean obviously
it was very soft but
that was stuff i mean back in the 90s
back in the 80s and 90s
unless your dad had porn magazines
which my dad did um
you you know you you kind of had to take
what you could get
you said the car wasn't [ __ ] though man
[ __ ] softcore softcore was actually
the king of softcore would have been
[ __ ] um russ myers it's for a long
time
yeah seriously you should read it i have
his it's a biography of him yeah and
it's
it's very very entertaining you should
probably read it russ meyer's gonna have
to do it over there on the shelves yeah
he could make a porn movie that didn't
have any porn in it
basically and just
but it was artistically filmed he made
you think there was porn in it
just big boobs and strange situations
sometimes though i'm gonna say look well
you know it's hard for me to say because
i'm a girl
so
a lot of times sometimes to me
the softcore porn movies
are hotter than like hardcore porn or
like gonzo kind of porn because
imagination well yeah well to me like a
lot of
str particularly straight porn is
mechanical
in a way that it's just kind of like
close-ups of body parts and stuff and
that's not really that sexy to me or
that's not appealing though that's what
i mean
most everything is mundane so that's
what i mean so a lot of times sometimes
like if i see a movie that i'm actually
like really invested in like oh i'm i'm
really into the characters and all this
stuff and then there's like a soft core
sex scene in there that's like way
hotter than seeing some [ __ ] i
don't know who they are like just
banging their parts together in a random
context list
the cutting edge [ __ ] is not even pro
it's [ __ ] individual creators some
chick with her phone
or a [ __ ] couple with their phone in
the car
that's really the the cutting edge of it
because those people are not really
doing it for the money per se
they're doing this [ __ ] for the love of
it
the pro [ __ ] is kind of
stale a lot of it well a lot of times
you just kind of feel like they're just
doing it like i said for the money and
yeah
and a lot of times particularly like if
you're a woman like watching porn i kind
of feel like a lot of the women don't
really look like they're having that
good of a time they're just kind of like
yeah yeah great okay where's my money
the best of the pro stuff and it peaked
with [ __ ] belladonna
in the 90s see now i thought she was
great because she looked like she was
just legitimately having a blast well
that's because she would not work with
people that she didn't know right it's
like groups of friends and the way they
did it was right and and she was
way into that [ __ ] yeah she was super
into and you could tell that she was
super into it and they're not making her
screw anybody she didn't like
okay they were all friends of hers so
you're gonna get a better product to
this day belladonna stuff [ __ ] still
some of the best is it it i'd probably
put her
in general
as the best porn star of all times
[ __ ] belladonna i like her a lot
actually from biloxi mississippi because
like i said she seems like a chick you
could just like hang out with yeah she
doesn't look super fake she looks like
just a regular purse she's pretty she's
a goth girl though and she's kind of
like a goth girl but she
doesn't like like she doesn't look like
fake
and i mean she looks like she's having a
good time yeah the thing i don't like a
lot about a lot of porn is that a lot of
the women don't look like they're really
having that good time they're just kind
of like putting up with it well a lot of
them have a lot of them drug problems
this is a profession that they didn't
choose it's kind of like to have to do
it and a lot of it is kind of like
that's the demo tape for [ __ ]
prostitution services [ __ ]
yeah that's uh
and it comes across so it's just kind of
like yeah okay whatever
cream pie whatever bobby bill but
belladonna was at a time where
the internet wasn't fully matured so
they could still make a lot of money
through vhs well and she like and i was
in a lot of competitions and she kind of
like was kind of an entrepreneur too
because she has like a whole bunch of
like even i don't know about now but a
few years ago
i was at fairvilla like the big adult
superstore like here in orlando
and she has a [ __ ] kind of like branded
character
branded products so she's like very
entrepreneurial in that so she's like
really into it and that really comes
across in her stuff which is probably
why i like her stuff more than any other
things but like i said in general and
like i said i'm not speaking for
everybody obviously because everybody's
different but in general
women tend to prefer
written erotica because you can fill in
your own
blanks you can fill in your own
imagination they like to come up with
their own [ __ ] they don't really yeah i
i don't really like a lot of the visual
stuff because it takes you out of it you
know what i'm saying it doesn't like
leave any room for you i'm just watching
two people i don't know who they are
yeah or two people three people five
people whatever it is they're just like
banging and i'm just like okay but
who are these people like how do they
know each other like this is not
it's not that all that hot yeah now this
it sounds strange talking about porn in
the mainstream but it's not strange it
never was strange it goes all the way
back to [ __ ] ancient greece the
cradle of western civilization
they had
a profession of women called pornei and
pornei that's where the word porn came
from they were porn stars
but they didn't have tv
it was live you hired them to come to
parties
and
they
had famous ones and super expensive ones
and they would do
live shows at parties and if the money
was right it was you know audience
participation at the party
you know at a party back then was you
know you see that [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know in some of those uh
roman movies you know like [ __ ] like
what was that gladiator movie where you
know they hire a bunch of entertainers
to come over but they were not slaves
they were free women
some of them might have been but they
were you know free women also did that
too
and rome had that kind of stuff they
weren't they didn't have just
prostitutes they had
nude dancers for parties which were
performers they're performers
uh and my understanding some of the
gladiatorial events also kind of had
things like porny and before the hunts
would happen which they were kind of
strippers basically
and you know the coliseum was filled
with prostitution you had prostitutes
working the crowd too there's a lot of
you know
so this is always part of civilized
western society
uh and just
the venue changes you know the method of
delivery changes but it has always been
around sex and violence
big sellers
big way of moving up
one of the one of the roman emperor's
wife was basically a poor name and
everybody knew it
but and but everybody loved her she was
great she was evidently a real competent
intelligent self-made woman
although the roman aristocracy were
horrified but she was an empress
well i told you i'm actually kind of
fascinated by because you know for a
large portion of human history women
didn't have a lot of the same rights as
men
so
when you see stuff i read this great
book about victorian era
uh
women that own brothels
yeah
and
like taking a peek into that lifestyle
is just fascinating because like i said
in a lot of ways they had a lot more
power and a lot more freedom than women
that were more respectable at the time
yeah like other people like maybe look
down on them a little bit but [ __ ] them
not not so much that it like affected
their life and anything yeah what she's
talking about is there was that was
stuff that was happening in the south
you had
very powerful brothel owner women
that were heavily connected with law
enforcement and and [ __ ] the
governors and [ __ ] mayors
and
they were doing things like throwing
elections in other words getting
making sure a certain candidate won an
election
uh law enforcement was helping them and
they were
even doing things like assassinations
and [ __ ]
political assassinations
don't underestimate the people of the
past they were every bit if not more
competent than people over the present
they didn't let the paradigms of their
time hold them back
they played through that [ __ ]
or they made those parent they made
those limitations work for them too
people were crafty they're always crafty
yeah well there's always going to be
like that kind of upper tier subset of
people that
even if they see like all the
limitations decided well how can i work
that to my advantage that's what they
were doing and like i said i kind of
feel like that's why i'm fascinated by
women that you know own brothels and
stuff like that like back at a time
like i said when women didn't really
like weren't really allowed to like have
jobs or anything like that
but they found like a way to work around
all the rules and
honestly like there it's really really
admirable i thought even in the
greco-roman age on paper women weren't
didn't have much power but that was only
on paper the writers of the time said no
they were actually like the power behind
the throne most of the time
men listen to women
they do they do no they don't yeah they
do
they listen to women well no they
listened to their opinions and there was
because there's a lot of [ __ ]
intrigue and court stuff that has to
happen
you know
men would listen to him
zach brought up jenna jameson
read her uh autobiography i can't
remember the name of it right now but i
checked it out of the library several
years ago and it's
fascinating yeah like she i mean she
seemed like a nice a nice girl so but
her the book that she writes matt is big
it's like she wrote like this big long
book but um it's yeah i i really really
enjoyed it it's a fun book
um
grifter says porn has gotten weird
too much anal stepsister fake incest
yeah there is a large subset of that
that's cause you're looking for it
though you're looking for weird shoes no
well no no the algorithms were from
whatever kind of weirdness no from what
i've heard yeah
um you know i don't like i said i don't
really go looking at a lot of porn
because i'm a girl and we don't do that
kind of stuff but yeah not generally
but yeah a lot of it is kind of like you
know anal stuff which yeah okay whatever
um but there is a lot of like weird yeah
but yeah that's not that weird that's
not the word but there is a lot of like
family stuff like oh this is my
step-daughter or this but there's a lot
of that going on just like anything else
there's trans
and yeah that seems like a big trend
it's constantly trying to [ __ ] break
some [ __ ] taboo and trends and [ __ ]
you don't take any of that [ __ ]
seriously because it's a world of
fantasy and it's all fake none of those
people are related they're [ __ ] with
you they're trying to get you to click
click bait selling product
selling new product it's a normal market
well it's not so much i think the thing
about the most interesting thing about
porn to me is not the stuff that's made
but the fact that it's like why they're
making it and like why so many people
are clicking on it why
for example and i'm not judging i'm just
wondering
why is it so common nowadays for people
to be so into
like for example like stepsister porn
okay like you know what i mean
i'll explain that's what i'm saying
that's just a generalization i'm not
saying like specifically but explain it
because i'll explain it because um
[ __ ] i study what the hell's
happening and i have a background in
sales
and i have an understanding of
psychology
if you look at porn where nothing's
really said
nothing
it falls to the bottom okay if you look
at porn where things are being said it
moves to the top
because really what people are
what people are selecting
is some kind of an excitement factor in
with the with
and they're bored with actual physical
acts now they're into these
psychological acts
well and i kind of feel like they can
only be that can only taboos
well no it's not just because that's
just one of them
the sexiest thing about a human being is
the mind not really the body's part of
it but a lot of us what's happening well
i agree with that
and a lot of a lot of it comes from
what's being said
this goes back to some of the classic
porn stars going back to the 70s 80s and
90s
when they hired girls they'd hire them
for their looks but who rose to the top
was who could act
okay
and that was that was consistent
throughout even the video age who could
act the porn stars that could convince
you that something was real
or convince you that they were really
reacting to what was happening
were the ones that were the most popular
yes well those girls could talk
if the [ __ ] opened her mouth and it
[ __ ] turned you off
they were not popular
if she didn't say anything they were not
that popular sorry i just if they could
open their mouth and [ __ ] say
something to turn you on they [ __ ]
move to the top if you actually look to
say belladonna
part of a lot of belladonna's appeal is
what she says
she because she sounds
you know she sounds authentic
she says things
for some reason like when you said that
the first thing that popped into my head
yeah was the scene from the man with two
brains where he's going to like kill
that prostitute that he picks up yeah
and she's like super super hot and she's
like naked underneath the fur coat yeah
and then she starts talking and she has
this like horrible like really annoying
voice yeah it's my voice isn't it yeah
yeah dm you know what i mean and it's
like that was the first thing i thought
of i don't know why
yeah it's all that weird the incest [ __ ]
is [ __ ] getting [ __ ] turned
on by the weirdness of what's being said
not so much what's being happen what
what's happening
well i think like i said i think this is
kind of like analogous to
the reason why a lot of people like to
watch
dumbasses like us
on youtube and i'm not saying like i do
that too like i just watch like random
ass people in their own houses on
youtube talking about their lives or
whatever
but
i think that people like
the real experience yeah and i think
that that also extends to porn i mean at
least in my situation like i'm not
speaking for everybody obviously and i'm
not a dude so i'm not like the main uh
you know kind of audience for it
but
it's much hotter for me
if this is somebody that i know or that
i feel like i know because i've watched
them in other non-porny situations
and then you see them in that situation
you know what i mean because there's
context behind it
i think the reason that a lot of women
don't like
porn
is because there's no context like i
said it's just a bunch of like random
ass strangers who may or may not be hot
but i'm like i don't know them and i
don't know what their relationship is i
don't know what's going on that's what
i'm saying so yeah well yeah that's what
i was trying that's what i was trying to
do
if nothing is said that's baseline it's
kind of like neutral there's something
said and it turns you off that's
negative if something's said and it
[ __ ] turns you on that's [ __ ] way
positive
when i look back over my whole [ __ ]
life
your whole life whole [ __ ] life no
i'm talking about going back to my
teenage years
knocking these women down that's high
school [ __ ] time that's really how
you look at it knocking them down or
they were knocking me down like they
could have been knocking me down [ __ ]
you know
sucking the life out of you in the
[ __ ]
drive-in
it wasn't so much what happened is what
she [ __ ] said
you know and what led up to it it was
the mind [ __ ] behind it like i said it's
context yeah yeah so maybe you're not
that different from a girl in that no
yeah no dude is
that's wrong but here's the deal if
nothing said if nothing's said it's just
kind of neutral
it's okay
because at least you saw it you did it
but if some [ __ ] was said and it went
down okay
then it's [ __ ] huge bonus and if it's
w and if if it was kind of wrong it was
even better like if she
if she was cheating on her boyfriend
when this [ __ ] happened even better
that's what i [ __ ] loved it when she
was cheating with she's cheating on her
boyfriend [ __ ] around me
it's like it's like getting laid five
that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying i kind of feel
like that's maybe why there's been a
rise in like maybe incesty kind of porn
like i said it's not real incest they're
just faking
it right um but i think there's maybe
because it's taboo still yeah i mean
that's still like a big taboo like
incest is still a taboo so i kind of
feel like anything that's kind of like
naughty and wrong
yeah there's always going to be more of
it i don't think that necessarily like
equates to like people doing that in
real life
i just think that because
the reason that it's so popular is
because it's not right because you know
you're not supposed to do it and that
makes it like dirtier so people are like
way more into it
you know yeah it was weird because it
didn't matter if i was cheating it only
mattered if she was cheating did you
ever cheat on anybody yeah background
attackable yeah i thought you had oh
yeah
he's like he's like oh yeah oh yeah
yeah well i wasn't like i was married to
him or anything you know what i mean
just dayton
grantham's was there
a lot of that high school [ __ ] i did
yeah you cheated on
but you know what i mean you're [ __ ]
in your teens
you weren't going to marry her that
[ __ ] was going to go off to college in
a year so anyway you knew it you know
but it didn't matter that i was cheating
it mattered if if the girl i was messing
with if she was cheating it was even
better
it was kind of like being dominant over
some other dude
well yeah i can see that's kind of like
what it was it was like that yeah yeah i
got your woman you're indirectly yeah i
got you i stole your woman oh i was
[ __ ] into that yeah
well you're still kind of into that
because you used to tell people i mean
you haven't said this in a long time but
for a long time after we got together he
used to tell people that he stole me
from my yeah
but it wasn't true it's yeah not really
not really no no i was already like 95
percent of the way out like when i
started hanging out with you
you just kind of gave me that impetus
it's like yeah maybe i should just get
the [ __ ] yeah yeah you know what i
mean but yeah you didn't steal me that's
the thing it's like you're already going
yeah i feel like that's kind of like
yeah you can say that if you're [ __ ]
around but you can't like
heal anybody like because people have
their own like [ __ ] taking another
man's woman really only was only a big
thing when you're when you were in high
school that's what i'm doing that's
later on it didn't matter once you're
old like like like i said
when i met you i i was what 37 38 yeah
and i'm like you were older almost 40. i
was 40 maybe yeah you were like 39 or
41.
so it's like way too old to be like
indulging in that kind of [ __ ] but i do
remember i love talking [ __ ] though i
love you i like many people that i love
hyperbole
you love me i like i like hyperbole i'm
sure everyone here will be shocked at
that
[Laughter]
you have to well and that's the thing
that's
it keeps me jacked well that's kind of
the thing that people don't yeah
and i think everybody understands it now
but i think when you first moved here
yeah to florida because i've been here
my whole life but you just moved here
like
whenever it was yeah 2008 or whatever
the [ __ ] it was 2009.
and i think at first like people didn't
know quite much what to make of you like
people like you worked your way up in
the scene like people liked you because
you're like you're well you're a very
friendly person you're a very outgoing
person and so like you but there was a
contingent that were like well he's kind
of an [ __ ] then you realize i had a
sense of humor and the thing about it is
that when i first met you like even some
people i knew were like man he's kind of
an [ __ ] i'm like yeah he is kind of
an [ __ ] but
it's fun like i know i'm asking he he
knows he's an [ __ ] and a lot of that
is just like bluster and like being
funny yeah like he doesn't actually i
don't think
i mean i've known you for a long time
but i don't think you actually believe
that you're kind of like the best thing
ever like like all the [ __ ] that you say
so i'm like a lot of it is just like
just for a comedic effect yeah you know
what i mean and i think a lot of people
didn't really get that they're like man
well it took him a while i think that's
like an air he's like an arrogant jerk
but yeah like after like now everybody
knows what your stick is so they're just
kind of like okay we get it
it's tom being tom you know what i mean
but i think like when you first arrived
here
you know opinions were divided opinions
were divided when i first started
hanging out with you
i got so
many uh
but here's i got a really lot of things
she being like you really shouldn't hang
out with that dude's really a dick but
you have to understand something the
dudes that were telling her that were
dudes that were trying to [ __ ] her
yeah well you know i did have like a
yeah i don't want to call him a stalker
he was like he was a low-key stalker
i mean but you know
yeah so i did but i kind of understood
that at the time but when he first like
i said he's not from here i'm from here
and so when he came here i think like
half the people kind of got it right
away like oh he's just [ __ ] with us
like he's just being like that like for
to be funny
and the other half were like oh my god
does he really think that he's that
awesome it's like that's really [ __ ]
so there was like a whole
i don't know like you guys it was a
whole thing it was a whole thing and i
had like several people like
message me and be like jenny why are you
hanging out with like that dude such a
dick and blah blah so yeah it was a
whole thing but i think everybody's like
pretty much like on the same page with
you now
and they just you know so they're just
kind of like yep are you worried about
those people that's tom that's what a
lot of those people a lot of people
you're talking about are gone well yeah
granthar says
hard to believe people used to watch
porn in movie theaters back in the 70s
and 80s yeah like what else were you
gonna do before they had a home video
sitting in a dark theater with a bunch
of dudes tugging away is very low on
granthar's list of a fun time
grandma kun says [ __ ] i remind him of
the general from [ __ ] doctor strange
yeah thank you very much yeah thank you
very much that was [ __ ] uh yeah you
got you got me right that's it that was
another movie we haven't done
we haven't done doctor strangelove yeah
yeah well bucky [ __ ] uh what was his
name kilgore no no [ __ ] that was
something that was uh
from apocalypse now uh
it was george c scott
and who the who they were talking about
was uh
kurt kurt lemay
curtis lemay was
the very first um general of the us air
force he helped create the u.s air force
because uh the united the american air
force started off as the us army air
corps in world war ii but it got so big
that it had to become an entirely
different branch it became the air force
and kurt lemay
supervised the
the bombing in japan all right and i
think also germany and yeah he's kind of
famous yeah he was exactly like that
character from
dr strangelove but better
he was even better
there's a bunch of ufo conspiracies
behind him some stuff people that knew
him
uh mcnamara
asked him about the ufos and the may
grabbed him and says don't you ever
ever ask me about that ever again
which has kind of caused a bunch of
[ __ ] like what did he know you know
cause like why would he react that way
yeah right yeah and lemay walked around
the [ __ ] cigar and
during world war ii they were saying you
know [ __ ] uh they were talking about
whether or not we were going to win the
war because well we better win the war
if not the world will all be killed as
war criminals and he was absolutely
right
because i mean at least he had enough
self-awareness he knew exactly what he
was
because we bombed 63 japanese cities and
killed like [ __ ] like 20 million
people like i said it had to be lost
we'd be in bed yeah men women and
children we burned to death
not only in japan but also in germany
okay
uh the old school america was hardcore
they we not in a good way
well they did what they had to do but i
wouldn't have gotten involved in world
war ii i would have [ __ ] let world
war ii play itself out we really had no
dog in that fight it didn't really
matter if commies or nazis ran europe
um
so really we shouldn't got involved in
that now japan attacked pearl harbor but
we were [ __ ] with japan so we kind of
asked for it we put an oil embargo
against them
because they were [ __ ] up china which
really had nothing to do with us
you know
well i mean the us kind of has a long
history of like involving ourselves and
stuff that doesn't it started in world
war one
and it goes against everything america
was supposed to be about we were
supposed to be basically isolationist
because we have enough landmass and
enough resources to be iso isolationist
you know smaller countries don't have
that luxury
but we really wasted a bunch of blood
and a bunch of gold
in [ __ ] with these other countries
let them kill each other it has nothing
to do with us
and morality has nothing to do with it
either
okay it doesn't matter if nazis and
comedies kill each other
okay neither one of them were any good
uh
and what you ended up with is a ruling
class here in the united states that
thinks it runs the world all right and
that's big problem for us which that's
all coming to a head now
we cannot tell other people how to live
we do not have the military to do so all
right these people are [ __ ] dreaming
all right and uh you're going to see it
all coming down soon we're going to go
back to the way we were before the world
wars
hopefully
after we sort out problems between
americans if that's possible we'll see
granthar says full disclosure
grantham thought tom was kind of an
[ __ ] in high school yeah but now he
finds him well you're still kind of yeah
yeah yeah yeah i was yeah uh but now
finds gonna be an interesting study in
contrast and a wise man with deep
knowledge thank you brother
it's all a sense of [ __ ] humor okay
yeah i know i'm abrasive
but that's a good word for it yeah
you're you are very abrasive but it's
you gotta have a sense of humor uh i'm
gonna tell you the truth you know and
and granthar said yeah i have a hobby in
view but it's a true it is of course
it's true
and it's not a truth that i learned it's
a truth that i saw and that's how i
learned it nobody taught me this i saw
it
you know saw i read books
i read books when i was young that ended
up being true and they all have to do
they're all old books
okay
um
i was influenced by the german
philosophers
you know scope
schopenhauer
and nietzsche
both of them
uh [ __ ] can't he full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
but he also true and in buddhism
some of the tenets behind the true
truisms of buddhism
uh yeah i'm big into that um very much
into uh the bible [ __ ] uh red [ __ ]
uh decline of fall roman empire the long
version okay the what the [ __ ] big
i think it was four or five [ __ ] huge
books boring boring as [ __ ] but you see
how history just repeats itself over and
over again and that there's no hope you
give up hope in this
oh [ __ ] look at this
florida but gibbon gibbon was great
thunder um
so and coming up in a military academy
as a kid you know [ __ ] i have what
you would call a classical education
and that's held together over time
um
humans are what they are you're not
going to change that
the ancient people we laugh at them we
think they're savages but they were the
way that they were because of how we are
and you're not going to change that
the future is going to look like the
past
there'll be technology but
the future will look like the past
because it has always been that way
we're in the 21st century
this is a temporary thing if you're an
american and in the west
it will go it will revert to the mean
because it always has
and it's happening now
and that's a good thing
it's a good thing it'll all work out
difficulties and trials is what makes
people strong it's what made people
happy
if i put you into heaven where you had
no problems you'd be miserable
well it'd be boring after a while
yep
i mean the thing about it though i kind
of feel like yeah um
obviously history repeats itself but
every time that it goes through the
wheel
we make like a
tiny tiny tiny like centimeter
of progress
but it takes a really really long time
but most of that progress is usually
technological it's technological usually
mostly technological which like i said
it and that's nothing to sneeze at
because that does actually like make
life better for many many people
uh and we've made like strides in a lot
of other ways too but
yeah i mean we always have that kind of
like thing that we have to fall back on
but we all lived in one of the greatest
parts in all of [ __ ] mankind the
advent
of the internet
the internet changed thing i never would
have imagined it
i was listening to billy idol's album
cyberpunk where he [ __ ] foresaw all
this [ __ ] he was reading the right [ __ ]
about what
virtual reality and internet how that
would change the world he was right
it's creative and destructive
simultaneously to make well like
most everything things
the act of creation is also an act of
destruction
it's it's a single act
and we're living through that right now
the main
question for humanity right now is will
we become cyborgs
and become machines or will we remain
human beings
we're in what
frank hubert would call
the butlerian jihad
okay that's that's what we're doing
i am fighting for humanity
that we shall remain machines
we shouldn't become cyborgs
we'll remain machines they should be
good we will remain humans
i'm team cyborg yeah we should not
become cyborg
you take cyber cybernetic implants into
yourself
and hook yourself up to you
into the internet you'll become the borg
from star trek and you won't run the
borg
some billionaire will
he'll be given godlike powers over you
more power than any government
and it'll become a totalitarian system
do not become a cyborg honestly i'm kind
of more of an advocate of i like some of
the ideas
of being a cyborg
um
but
you have to retain like a certain
percentage of you must be an individual
humanity right sure
because what will happen is they'll try
to do something out of black mirror
remember those black mirror [ __ ]
warnings that's what they'll do
because if the look take take this free
implant chip and you can upload yourself
to the internet and you'll live forever
but in the fine princess but will
control everything you do and say
and if you piss us off we'll delete you
that kind of weird [ __ ]
and then they'll they'll control you
you can only have that [ __ ] if you're
free
you want to take that [ __ ] if it frees
you not if it not if it interests you
see the thing about it i think that
what i i was weirdly randomly thinking
about this earlier today
i was like because i know we've talked
earlier about
for example like downloading our
consciousness into like an avatar like a
cyborg type of body in an internet which
like i said i would be totally down for
that but
uh there would have to be like a caveat
attached to that where you would have to
be able to choose your own parameters
right um
you know it you would have to like be
able to curate your own experience
essentially i don't really like the fact
of there being like limitations about
stuff like if they gave you like all of
the like yeah you could have this much
humanity you could have this much cyborg
thing you could still
enjoy like for example you could still
enjoy food and sex and stuff like that
but not feel any pain or something like
that so you could have like
a whole experience that you actually
picked then yeah that would be fine but
if they're not going to hold up to them
if they're not going to let you pick
then yeah that would be fun yeah that
would be [ __ ] up because what they
would do is this is well now we have
your soul in this grid
and
you will do this or we will delete you
you know i mean and [ __ ] then they
got your ass
and you also
so you
i would like all that stuff but i would
like to have autonomy individual
autonomous yeah i mean like i said if
somebody said that i could download my
consciousness into like an avatar that i
could change every day right um and i
could live forever essentially
then yeah that i want to do that but
i would be i would want to be able to
like choose what the experiences that i
had and like what i wanted and like what
i could
what i could do in within those
parameters right if i can't choose that
then i don't want to do it but here's
the deal if that if that technology was
very mature you would have your what
so-called internet life and you would
have your real life
because you would still have a physical
avatar or a [ __ ] robot of you
in the actual real world doing stuff
see that's something that people don't
realize
you'd be living two lives
a life in this world and a life in the
online world and there would also be
crossed over
if corporations were involved they would
try to control both of those aspects
about what you could do and what you
couldn't do and you don't want that
you want to be in a situation where
you're free you're not free to say
murder people
but you're free yeah i mean you're free
to think what you want you're free to
vote the way you want to vote or
whatever
and uh they may not want to hear that
but i think eventually
if you looked
if you looked at say frank hubert's work
they were eventually able to fight their
way through the butlerian jihad
and make sure that technologies like
that
either didn't happened or they weren't
obtrusive
you had like it's always like a balance
it's always you always have to strike a
balance right like i said you can't like
just [ __ ] on you can't be a luddite you
can't like [ __ ] on every technology
because a lot of technologies actually
do make a lot of people yeah yeah
they're good um and i would properly and
i would absolutely not want to go back
in time because
holy [ __ ] like before the 20th century
people died of easily preventable
diseases you know that's just one
example
technology you're supposed to free
people not in sleep that's what i'm
saying so
yeah so you have to really strike a
balance between
you know uh the the progress that we're
making is this actually like helping
people or is this stymieing right people
like so you have to kind of have some
people were saying yeah this doesn't
apply to today though these are
corporations you can't control them
[ __ ]
you don't know american history
the most powerful [ __ ] corporation
the most powerful [ __ ] businesses and
technologies of all times in american
history were the railroads
railroads are more powerful than the
government
they can say for a time they were yeah
for a while they could say [ __ ] this
town they didn't agree with us we're
going to stop deliverance we're going to
like we're going to go around this time
hold the railroad running around that
yeah that town died died yeah okay so
they were very powerful
for a while for a while but other
technologies caught up cars
cars got rid of that
because roads went everywhere and then
nobody cared about that they [ __ ] the
railroad
right i mean they're still around for
you know uh you know
mostly i think the railroads use
nowadays for
like farm stuff cargo cargo and then uh
me and santa that were talking about
this and there are other sources that
probably that other sources have
mentioned this probably very secret
when you look at the american map
we did a show on this
when you look at the interstate system
on the american road map
it follows that it looks just like that
under the ground
that there are underground railroads
between especially between military
bases
when have you ever seen a nuclear
missile or a nuclear warhead
travel above ground
they would never do that
we have badass [ __ ] boring
technologies
and we've had almost what 70 or 80 years
yeah i'm sure they have like all kind of
there's all kinds of underground train
tracks
underneath the united states to me that
seems like not really that shocking a
revolution because i'm sure they're
[ __ ] doing that and you look at the
military budget it's huge
and then i look at places like north
korea and i know that north korea is
mostly underground it's
it has an underground complex
it's pretty [ __ ] vast because they're
expected they expect to be hit by
nuclear missiles and they have people
down there digging you know
in england said pain is just a lesson
learned you know what's interesting is
that the other day i was watching that
show the unexplained
uh it's on hulu with william shatner i
think it was from 2019
and they did a whole episode
about people
who couldn't feel pain
which on the surface sounds awesome but
they were talking about how
maybe not so cool
because they could actually like act you
know physically hurt themselves but they
don't feel anything like hey i'm just
like talking to you over here and my
hand is like resting on a stove top and
i don't feel any pain so i don't realize
it and then like i burn my hand off so
it was that kind of thing so they talked
about that um
but the thing about it is that
if you hypothetically
inhabited
a cyborg body
you would hope that the cyborg body if
something was wrong with the body that
you were in
um
it would give you some kind of warning
of it like it would flash a light at you
or something it wouldn't necessarily
have to
manifest itself as pain you know what i
mean
you know the reason that humans have
pain is because it's warning you about
some hey something's wrong you should
like check this out so that's why
there are some people that don't feel
any pain and it sounds cool but it's
actually like um
not really that good because that's your
body's warning system
but if you are not no longer inhabiting
an organic body anymore
i would think that there could be some
other better way of alerting you that
something was wrong rather than the
sensation of pain but uh but i would
hope that they would be able to give you
the sensation of like like good things
like i said i would still like to be
able to like taste delicious food for
example oscar's telling me to shut this
[ __ ] down what time is it that was a
long time ago okay that was a long time
okay don't worry about it he's just
[ __ ] around he's [ __ ] with me i'm
just gonna [ __ ] this [ __ ] again if i
shut this [ __ ] down oscar i'm gonna put
it on you so everybody knows that you
told me to shut it down no it's only
been two hours dude we've only been two
hours that's like so short because we're
gonna get we're gonna get some food here
in a while what are you what are you
gonna make uh i got hamburgers i got
yeah how about a hamburger
yeah that'll work okay i mean you know
uh chocolate bacon cheese burger with
[ __ ] well now let's not get crazy no
i got the bacon and the cheese i got the
guacamole they got everywhere
well it doesn't matter if you have it
i'm just saying
do i want all that on there
you just wanna i don't have any i don't
have any lettuce
do you have any tomatoes uh
uh yeah yeah i got the little the little
tomatoes i would like guacamole cheese
and tomatoes okay not really any bacon
though why use bacon bits the real bacon
bits
i know okay
uh yeah oracle says we had greek food
for dinner tonight that sounds good
actually we don't have any greek food in
a while you haven't made it in a while
yeah you used to make greek food quite a
bit yeah we have a one of our closest
friends is greek yeah and he keeps
trying to have sex with me
that's awesome so they're trying to be
these greek dudes just trying to have
sex said look i'm not greek like that
and he's like [ __ ] busted in i'm
saying
your wife will get mad and she's like
[ __ ] no she'll videotape it no i was
looking around probably i'm [ __ ]
around that's usually that's dimitri
that's a buzzer beat you pop is in his
[ __ ] wife i'm just i'm always [ __ ]
with him about being greek and [ __ ] if i
could
we'll be sitting there we're talking
serious business or something and then
the [ __ ] he says something about
[ __ ] gayness and i said well you're
greek you did you do that [ __ ] and he's
like oh man [ __ ] you
i flip it back around on him in england
said greek food is the best it is i mean
greek food is is actually very good yeah
i'm gonna say like last time i was on
vacation
in saint augustine
um i didn't realize this at the time
because i was there for like a week
but i can't remember what day it was but
like mondays are tuesdays like all the
restaurant almost all the restaurants
are closed because it's one of those
days where and i was just like [ __ ] man
i want some dinner and the only
restaurant that was open was a greek
restaurant
and i went and i went in there and it
was and i was the only you all right i
looked over there and it fell down
okay
and i was the only person in there and i
was like well at least thank god you
guys are open i'm like i'm i'm dying
i've been walking around for like
12 hours at this point and i'm like
starving to death
so i went in there and like yeah the
food is like actually really good i
think that place is called athena it
might still be there it's probably still
there now that i'm thinking about it but
yeah i mean
you made great food
of youtube that makes it a lot i may
have made it and yeah that shit's like i
can't remember what it was though that's
very very good
um it was chicken i think wouldn't it i
can't actually remember yeah found a
long time so i made it john gore said
you should do a show on susan cabot she
was a b actress worked with a lot with
roger corman that was a long time ago
she was like
well obviously you must be way back
no no i'm at the bottom okay
i mean unless i'm not getting updates on
the chats okay let me see
it's only like four
comments yeah you're right you're right
you're right yeah
well thank you you're right
he admitted that i was right about that
that's amazing listen to how she does um
thank you very much for the super chat
okay so i am super chat
but said she was later involved with
money super jet with deep state intrigue
in the middle east there you go thank
you very much john robertson hey guys uh
made a live stream finally uh love you
guys finally found a cheaper vincent
price collection ooh with several films
on it my favorite is mask of the red
death that's probably honestly
not gonna lie it's probably my favorite
too and honestly that's probably my
favorite egg round pose story
and
i just love like the imagery of it i did
a whole i designed i don't know if you
guys know this but i designed a whole
board game
around
mask of the red death and it's it's
called the red death and the board looks
like
the mansion with all the different
colored rooms in it and stuff like that
oracle said jenny is usually right i
know
and girls always tom would never admit
that but no she's right about a lot of
stuff yeah yeah
thank you very much that you admitted
that's amazing that's amazing you
admitted that
but yeah so she's not like me though she
can't predict the future i predict the
future i'm well nostra thomas okay
i don't bother predicting the future
because
why
to me it seems like a pointless exercise
and i'm because i'm a man and i don't
really like points because i'm amazing
i don't like pointless
all right good
to me it seems like a waste of time and
honestly it seems like a waste of time
just saying like oh this is going to
happen in the future i'm like i don't
know if that's going to [ __ ] happen
and then like if it doesn't happen then
you're going to look like an [ __ ] and
i was like i'm just
i don't i don't understand the point of
it i just can i just understand human
beings and know how an [ __ ] is going
to act
[ __ ] gonna i know how an [ __ ] is
gonna act well that's one thing that
you're good at like you're you're good
at predicting the behavior of [ __ ]
[ __ ] right
[ __ ] right i don't i'm not exactly
how i am i'm not entirely sure if that's
something to be proud of or not but you
know it's a survival skill
i came up
having to know what how i well to be
honest with you i don't know like i'm
coming at it from a different angle than
you but uh to be honest i've kind of
like lived my entire life i'm like i'm
just gonna assume that everybody is the
worst
so i'm just gonna live my life
accordingly you know you know what i
mean it's like and it's that's the lazy
way of going about it because you don't
have to like predict anyone's behavior
you're just like well i'm just
predicting that you're just going to do
the worst [ __ ] thing possible
so john says i'm an asologist yeah
exactly exactly he's a boobologist
and
like i said
you're very good at that
not sure like i said not sure that's
something i could predict when the [ __ ]
is gonna die
i do that quite regularly so that
like she's gonna die
a couple months later [ __ ] dead [ __ ]
man the second you point at me and say
that i'm gonna be like worried about it
i'm gonna be worried about it yeah
[ __ ] just yeah
patriots revenge says uh cask of
monteato for me i mean all right i
i love edgar allan poe
i love all of his stories mask of the
red death probably my favorite although
i don't know it's kind of a tie i think
like uh mask of the red death and
telltale heart
is also because i think that was the
first one of his that i read and that
was the first story and i was a little
kid when i read that
that was the first story
that introduced me to the concept of the
unreliable narrator
and
it kind of blew my mind a little bit
that
somebody that was telling you the story
was crazy
and that kind of that opened up like a
lot of possibilities for me like when i
read that at the time you know what i'm
saying yeah it was that and there was
another story and i know this is one is
a little bit obscure i might have talked
about it like on one of my other things
but there was a story by
um
h russell wakefield who i kind of feel
like is probably not all that well known
in the us but he's kind of like a little
more famous in the uk like as a ghost
story writer and he wrote a story called
the triumph of death which i read when i
was very little
and it's basically about this old lady
that lives in a haunted house that she
[ __ ] knows is haunted
and it's uh some gilda ray kind of [ __ ]
like torture and everything
um she knows it's haunted but she has
like all these slightly younger women
like in their 40s that are her
companions
but she pretends the house isn't haunted
because she thinks it's funny to like
gaslight them
into not yet so
that story like [ __ ] me up because
that was one of the things
again just like the telltale heart where
i was like oh the [ __ ] telling you the
story
is
[ __ ] with you
and i think that was my first encounter
with that literary construct
and i was kind of like man that's like
that's [ __ ] up like that's some cool
[ __ ] so that was the first time i
encountered that so i think that was
kind of like
i don't know that like influenced a lot
of my like later writing i think okay
people please help us out hit that like
button please we only got three likes on
this video and you there's [ __ ] 30 of
you all in there please hit the like
button you'll help us with the
algorithms it does help you yeah oracle
says speaking po jenny have you heard uh
about t king fixtures kingfisher's new
book the one that's based on the fall of
the house of usher i have not but i
think it was you that recommended um the
other tea king fisher book the holo
places which i read before and actually
really really liked so i hadn't heard
about that but
holy [ __ ]
um yeah i need to get that and i'm going
to write it down right now because
yeah that sounds like it's like right up
my [ __ ] alley because man i like i
said i love edgar allan poe stuff
anybody that's doing edgar allan poe
stuff follow the house of usher and then
t
kingfisher and i'm gonna look that up
tomorrow
because that yeah that sounds like
something i want to read
john robinson trying to save the money
dressed like vincent price and follow
the house of usher me and tom could be
tweetsies
i mean
it wasn't like i said
the vincent price one
uh you know it was roger corman they
didn't have uh much money
so
it wasn't like i pictured it when i read
it but
i mean still it was the best screen
adaptation that i had seen and honestly
i don't think i've seen a better one
thus far
because
i don't know there was something about
the whole
i don't know i have a thing where it's
just kind of like i really like theming
like in a room
and i really liked the idea of this
suite of rooms it's like everything in
the room was like one color like all the
stained glass was one color and it's
like did everything in there was one
color and i was like yeah i'm into that
i don't know why like i have that
proclivity but okay but i have that so
it's like that was always something that
really stuck with me over the years and
that was something that i really liked
about that story i really liked the
whole thing too about
uh you know the red death being
a living embodiment of plague
you know what i mean like i really got
into that idea also
and
honestly like the roger corman version
as cheap jack as it is
is really like kind of the
quintessential adaptation of that i
haven't seen a better one i mean if you
know of one let me know but
i really haven't seen a better visual
adaptation of it kevin smith says that
youtube is unsubbing him from the
channel ain't that something
where they play games man i know they
play games
a lot of people [ __ ] i've complained
about that kind of stuff on other
channels that i listened to
i don't think i've had problems but the
thing about it is that i subscribe to so
many [ __ ] channels that if somebody
unsub me i would not notice
to be honest with you i mean i subscribe
i think my subscriptions
how many do i have
it's mostly horror channels but i have
like a bunch of other ones in there too
history kind of channels true crime
channels
cooking channels i have all kind of crap
in there
booktube kind of stuff you know what i
mean uh yeah oracle said it's so right
up your alley yeah that sounds exactly
what because like i said i really really
liked
uh the hollow places
so
that meets edgar allen poe yeah i'm into
that i remember i made it that
camp guy said i remember the first book
that made me experience emotional
sadness nine years old where the red
fern grows holy crap man
we read that in school i can't remember
how old maybe i was maybe nine i think i
was in elementary school or junior high
and
[ __ ] man
oh
and like not only did we read the book
but then like we watched the movie
adaptation of it
and i was just kind of like why the [ __ ]
why you want to do me that way
and it's only gotten worse over the
years because when i was a kid
excuse me
when i was a kid
bad enough that you're gonna like kill a
cat or dog or something like that but
and i didn't like it back then i like it
even less nowadays than i'm older
but
yeah like we went through that [ __ ] too
but i don't know like the first thing
a lot of that stuff kind of like
influenced me when i was a kid but
i think the first thing that
like i said i've read a lot of edgar
allan poe i've read a lot of edgar you
know uh hp lovecraft and stuff like that
when i was little
and that kind of like influenced a lot
of stuff but i think the first thing
that influenced me in the sense that
this is what made me want to be a horror
writer
was reading
books of blood
by clyde barker because no one stopped
me like my parents were just kind of
like whatever like do what you want so
they would take me to the library
and i checked
books of blood out when i was
probably 10 or 11 like much younger than
probably anyone should read that i'm
just saying
and i read it and it blew my [ __ ]
mind and i'd read stephen king like up
to that point and uh but after i read
like clyde barker so i'm like oh my god
this i want to do this i want to do what
this guy does
because the [ __ ] that he came up with
like stephen king [ __ ] is awesome i'm
not saying that but
it wasn't anything that was like
way outside of my own imagination or my
own experience whereas clyde barker he
was on like a whole other level like he
was coming up with some [ __ ] that i was
just like i didn't even think of that
how did you even think of that and
that's amazing so
i think that was what made me want to
write horror oh look pokey's on the show
yeah she's playing all kinds of games
what are you doing paul she was up in
the apartment up in her little apartment
for a minute and then she
well she goes up in the apartment but if
you come out of the because the
apartment is like right there outside my
office if you come like right out the
door
and if she wakes up and sees you and you
talk to her then she's like oh that
means it's play time and she'll like
comes out she'll be like and they'll
she'll come out and be like what are we
gonna do yeah yeah
yeah are we gonna are we gonna brush are
you gonna like give me some treats or
are we gonna like throw some mouse in
there and try to pull me into the
apartment
oh my goodness
john gore said old yeller had us all
crying in grade school yeah we did old
yeller too
i mean i don't really understand there
was a whole like sub genre
of
[ __ ] they made you read in elementary
and junior high where they killed cute
animals
to make you feel something
i'm not really sure what that says about
us as people like in the 1980s no we're
trying to get you to cry
it worked yeah it worked and uh to be
honest like we've read this stuff like
like i said where the word red fern
grows and old yeller we read both of
those and we watched the movie
adaptations
and
that's the thing even back then i was
just kind of like why
i'm in school
and it's bad enough that like people are
already like uh
you know there's a whole like situation
where people are like oh you're not cool
or whatever and then it's like you're
watching a movie about like a dog
getting shot and then you're going to
cry about it and then people are going
to tease you about it later well what
about watership down
that too yeah [ __ ] that was british
i read the book did you read the book no
just a movie
the book is if anything the book is
probably worse yeah
not even probably it's it is worse that
was a world war ii allegory it was yeah
i mean the book was like really
upsetting and then like when
well
that was the thing i kind of feel like
in the 80s
they just they wanted to make you feel
as shitty as possible
for or i don't know if that was what it
was but
they just wanted you to like deal with
the world i guess and they're trying to
teach you something they were trying to
teach you something yeah yeah
i mean
that's why i think a lot of like 80s
entertainment that was ostensibly for
children
was uh had some pretty [ __ ] up [ __ ]
they're trying to teach you that you got
it good
that it could get a lot worse that's all
it was i [ __ ] loved it as a kid
i liked it too like it [ __ ] me up like
i cried at a lot of the stuff but it was
supposed to it's about but that's what i
mean it's like yeah you can say that
like oh that makes me like a [ __ ] or
whatever but in a way i'm like well
that's how much you're supposed to read
that's how you're supposed to react
if you don't react to it then maybe that
means you're a sociopath it makes you
stronger
doesn't make you post it makes you
stronger because you realize
the deal of what could happen so you
appreciate things
and then when something bad happens
you have
you have
something to relate it to oh yeah this
is like in watership down when that
happened now i can i can overcome this
i just saw a video of [ __ ] i saw some
[ __ ] just [ __ ] man tom saw some [ __ ]
somebody posted a video
of these guys
on the side of the road
with video cameras and tripods trying to
record something
and a car in traffic stops
and a young black dude jumps out and
says are you videotaping me
are you are you taping me and he's
blowing up like he's a bad [ __ ]
like hey man no it's okay it's okay and
he swings at the guy
a little short fat stubby white dude
okay these are dudes
the black dude is probably 20 something
the white dude was maybe 30.
that little short fat white dude [ __ ]
hit that dude in the face with [ __ ]
spirits yeah mace
and that little black kid [ __ ] i'm gonna
call him a kid because he was only 20
lost it he's crying stumbling and
falling around and bouncing off of [ __ ]
somebody who'd never and i realized and
then he's like oh my gosh and then they
go it's okay man it's okay sit down
we'll call it like dude settle down the
same dudes that the same dudes that
[ __ ] maced him
are now
taking care of him the thing about it is
that
i just went and i went
this [ __ ] has never been hurt in
his life he's never even experienced
pain well he had no idea in my
experience uh dudes that go out there
and talk about how badass they are all
the time
um are usually like the first to crumble
when when [ __ ] hits the fan crumbled
not always but 99 of the time because if
they were actually bad asses yeah they
wouldn't have to go out there and like
talk about it
all the time they would just like
where my brother's at in the [ __ ]
comment section you got to go out there
and tell everybody
what a bad ass you are i've never seen
i'm going to kick your ass i'm going to
do this that and the other everybody's
like um yeah you're okay
no i'm american
okay
i'm american really
[Laughter]
[ __ ] yeah i serve with black dudes in
the infantry and [ __ ] i've i i've never
seen a weak black dude i just haven't
they they tend to be strong at least
some from my generation i've never seen
weakness like that out of
as somebody that i would consider uh to
be a man 20-something he had a nice car
and everything and i was just like
what happened
he wasn't hurt you know what i mean it's
like
we went through the gas chamber and
basic training was much worse than those
little [ __ ] sprays
and it was like he was dying
mean even me i'm like bro yeah as like
get your [ __ ] together yeah i'll show it
to you you'll laugh you'll laugh
together
the dudes that sprayed him had pity on
him
come on man like i said he probably
thought like me it's like
come on
and i'm not that bad what's happening
with these young people man i i don't
understand it well it was that
particular young person obviously yeah i
guess so somebody's he had never
encountered
he'd never countered adversity
well like i said maybe
um maybe one he was probably super young
and two
he'd probably like his bravado had maybe
like fooled people into thinking he was
a big badass but he never like met any
like yeah real trials his arms were
little though i mean he got away with it
well that's what i mean so when somebody
actually like stood up to him
well and i was a little white fat boy i
mean to be honest
even back it's not even like oh these
kids today or anything like that because
i kind of feel like back in the 80s
um i had experiences with
people that were like bullies
and the thing about it is that they
bullied
only to the extent that you
um
got back in their face if you got back
in their face then they would like
absolutely like yeah leave you alone
because bullies
by their nature
like to pick on somebody weaker yeah um
and the second that somebody like
actually stands up to them and can
actually like whip their ass or is not
afraid of them
then they're just like oh no like don't
like you know like not always but 99 of
the time that's usually what happens i
was amazed
that's usually what i was just doing so
i don't think that like i said i don't
think that's
the kids today but i think that happens
all the time because i had that
experience
i was amazed when i was like back in the
80s yeah
he came up out of that car the way he
was walking and i looked at his face i
didn't look at his body i looked at his
face in the video and he looked like he
was getting ready to whip somebody's
[ __ ] ass
uh but no but like i said the second you
spray him i'd have been scared
but then then he crumpled and then i i
backed it up and i looked at his his
[ __ ] arms and his body
it was all bluster there wasn't anything
there to back any of that up that's what
i'm saying and 99 of the time that's
usually i mean you can't
take that to the bank because every now
and then like you might get some like
crazy [ __ ] that's actually a
serial killer yeah but 99 of the time
people that [ __ ] with you like that are
if you actually like engage them and be
like yeah okay and like you go like that
they will be like okay nevermind yeah
never mind but you i mean you never know
when that's gonna be the situation
though so you really got to kind of
because i'm not generally scared of
people like that but
i've read about enough serial killers to
know that you can't actually
know which ones are
dangerous or patriots revenge watership
down damn i haven't thought about that
one in years yeah we watched it recently
and we were reviewing it oh god i looked
i'm looking at this [ __ ] me up i'm
looking at myself in the camera i got my
[ __ ] birth control glasses on you
know it's bad when i'm wearing my birth
control i like those gloves i bought my
i broke by the glasses so i had to put i
had did you sit on them you said no they
just wore out i got i broke my [ __ ]
birth control i got to wear a bird
control
damn i was going to tell you about that
it's [ __ ] storming like crazy out
there if we lose connections because the
storm i think it's okay at this point
just my weather thing down here and i've
never seen this actually it says 87
degrees which [ __ ] it's probably
like [ __ ] 100
and it says haze
i've never seen it say that ever yeah
uh oracle says pookie yeah she was up
there yeah yeah guama says for me i just
got to watch the land before time and
i'll ugly cry oh my god
i don't even like i don't want to watch
that before time which one before that
was an animated one about the dinosaurs
i
haven't seen it i got to see it honestly
a lot of times
i remember time before time or the time
land that time forgot
yeah i like that one that's a totally
different movie good movie saw it in
theater
um yeah oracle's talking about uh
watership down my heart has joined the
thousand for my friend stop running
today yeah it's like yeah
that book that book [ __ ] me up and the
movie [ __ ] me up classic british
literature
cause honestly and i'm not like ashamed
to say this but
i get real invested in stuff yeah like
books movies and stuff like that and
like i said i don't think that's i mean
i think that's a good thing if you don't
do that like probably maybe you're a
sociopath
but
there are certain things that i won't
watch
particularly like in the theater and
stuff like that because i know that i'll
cry yeah and i don't really want to do
that like in front of other people
so
i don't want to be like one of those
people and honestly we've had that
happen like a few times like a few times
we've gone to see like [ __ ] cartoons
and [ __ ] and like at the end i'm just
kind of like like this and i'm just
gonna
it's like so embarrassing what i want to
see next it's on tubey we saw it what's
it called strange world
or forbidden fantastic planet fantastic
planet i put it in the french one i put
it in the poll yeah i remember seeing it
as a kid
if it doesn't win then we'll do it for
uh
for a matinee i remember seeing it as a
kid it's animated it's a french movie
it's about politics but it's about being
controlled humanity being controlled by
aliens
and as a kid it blew me away but i don't
know what it would do to me as an adult
i got to see it again i remember loving
it
i mean fantastic like i said i'm and i
i recorded a video today about um some
of my favorite horror novels of the 21st
century i'm actually going to post it
tomorrow on scare salon
and one of the books in there which is a
grady hendrix book
um
actually kind of like made me cry a
little bit at the end which like i said
it's really good if you can do that
because
because you're
conjuring up fictional characters that
i'm reacting to as if they're real
people the last time that i actually
ugly cried at the end of a book
was probably um
at the end of his dark materials
like if you guys have read that uh
trilogy
yeah when i got to the end of that i
cried like a [ __ ] baby
so
the movie sucked but the books are
excellent if you haven't read those
uh yeah they're really and i don't
usually like fantasy kind of stuff
but
those were [ __ ] i got super super
into those those were really really good
and i totally totally cried at the end
not even embarrassed to say that
uh patriots revenge says true most of
the time the quiet ones are the ones to
fear that's what i'm saying you can't
really like the ones that are out there
telling you like i said how badass they
are
i'm this and we're going back to steven
seagal again
dudes that are going out there saying
it's like oh i was a navy seal and i was
just not in the other it's like you know
yeah i could kick that dude's ass come
on i'm not worried about that dude it's
dudes that you don't know anything about
what does that do dude he's just like
lurking over there and he's just kind of
being like if they're out there like
running their mouth
then
probably there's something to you people
in case you don't know you can't go
around saying you're a navy seal and
bullshitting around a bunch of people
that
that are veterans that know about all
that okay
you go around saying you're a navy seal
in a [ __ ] bar eventually this
motherfucker's gonna call you on it okay
i've seen it happen i've done some of it
i've coined [ __ ] if you know
what that means that's what i mean i
don't carry a coin anymore but honestly
like why would you go around like
saying something like that which one
is just inviting people to kick your ass
maybe
they are then maybe they want to get
their ass kicked i drove a [ __ ]
out of the damn biker bar who's my age
going on about how he was a door gunner
in the 82nd airborne division and did
all this [ __ ] there are no door
gunners in the 82nd airborne division
they don't have helicopters those are
all [ __ ] those are all [ __ ]
paratroopers c-130s c-141 c5 galaxies
that kind of [ __ ] there's no helicopters
in the 82nd okay
and he ran off after he saw my tattoos
oh you're from the 101st i was a door
gunner in the 82nd i immediately make
like an hour no
no you didn't no you didn't
and then he started to cry and cried oh
no you're not a brother and this and
that and i said no no no no stole a
valor and [ __ ] then he left
okay yeah well that's a lesson [ __ ]
get you quit shooting your mouth off
well one like quit lying about you right
i'm not good at that anyway so i would
never do that but
some people will go around like telling
you all kind of stories yeah and
yeah eventually somebody is gonna like
know what the [ __ ] you're talking about
right they're gonna call you out on the
[ __ ] so
don't do that it's much easier i was a
door gunner easier second to me like and
honestly like we've done a lot of shows
[ __ ] we just did a show on wednesday
about that [ __ ] that dissolved
people in acid yeah and his whole thing
was about fraud and everything
um i kind of feel like it's much easier
to just
be honest about stuff like when you're
making up these whole stories about [ __ ]
that you didn't do
right uh it's too difficult to keep
track of
and honestly like somebody somewhere is
gonna call you out on the crap they're
gonna know he told me he was a door
gunner and an air cav unit in the 82nd
the 82nd doesn't have air calve units
air cab units tend to be in leg
divisions like the [ __ ] second
infantry division they might have he's
just first in the night he's [ __ ]
throwing [ __ ] out of his [ __ ] ass
okay an air cav unit is an air assault
[ __ ] unit usually a an air assault
regiment
attached to a leg unit
you know which is non-airborne unit
yeah with like the like the second
infantry in korea they have cav units
okay but
don't [ __ ] with me man i will rape you
okay don't come at me with that [ __ ] you
know and then if i don't know if you say
some sideways [ __ ] i'll grab my [ __ ]
tablet and start searching through years
and where unit appointment was where
i'll find you
okay don't do that
but i can sense it
i sense it from dudes well like i said
the more that somebody like wants to
tell somebody about some stuff and like
brag about stuff yeah uh the less likely
it is that that [ __ ] i got [ __ ] i got a
[ __ ] i can't even brag about because i
didn't know xanada said do you do do you
realize that you were in tiger force and
i was like i wasn't in tiger and then i
went and you know i'm like oh yeah i
guess i was in tiger force which is the
cia front unit first first in the 327
recon i was in that unit in vietnam it
was called tiger force i didn't even
know that
all right and and my my platoon it was
only 40 dudes committed probably one of
the
the largest amount of war crimes pretty
much ever
in the u.s army history they were
beheading
babies and kicking it up the snatches of
[ __ ]
viet cong women they were doing weird
[ __ ]
yeah like that's some horror novel [ __ ]
right there well they were fighting
insurgents and they were being told to
do this
by the central intelligence agencies you
know this is before mercenaries were
around
so they were making my platoon do that
it's on wikipedia i'm not i'm not lying
but they arrested
the audience
um first 327 recon i was in that platoon
matter of fact i got the [ __ ]
i got
i got [ __ ]
the tattoos i got the yearbooks and [ __ ]
to prove it
i didn't even know about the unit
history during the time that i was in
there all that had been erased it was
just a badass recomplitum
that's all
it was mostly army rangers
i was getting short at the time and
[ __ ] um they wanted me to go to
ranger school so bad and they wanted me
to re-enlist and it was during the time
of drawdowns and you were lucky to get
an honorable discharge during in 1994
when i was there and i was so sick of
those [ __ ] then they basically
kind of kicked me out of first 327 recon
to do my last [ __ ] nine months in the
line [ __ ] alpha uh
i was uh
alpha company first three two seven the
last uh
nine months
and that was because [ __ ] i didn't
want to go to ranger school you know
ranger school back then was like going
to concentration camp
you'd lose all kinds of [ __ ] weight
they just beat the [ __ ] out of you it's
not like it is now
if you're in the army now you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
send me a send me a [ __ ]
you can send me a message instant
message i'll tell you i'll tell you why
you're a [ __ ]
it's all easy now
back in the 90s that [ __ ] was sh tough
and it was even tougher in the [ __ ]
80s
oh they're calling me now see why why
are they calling me because i mean i'm
[ __ ] i'm sure that's probably not why
they're calling me tom okay let me let
me have some show business yes paranoia
issues sorry it's okay
i'm drunk i'm drunk and i'm talking yeah
but
no it was sucking uh it was the [ __ ]
back when i was in
back in my day back in my day he sounds
like a grandpa no i've seen the [ __ ]
physical fitness requirements that y'all
are [ __ ] i've seen photographs you
guys are fat you're [ __ ] fat
okay
michael schaefer said tom do you
remember the movie they live
yes loved it i have it on blu-ray love
it we reviewed it like a long time ago i
mean they live as like a [ __ ] classic
bro so yeah we've reviewed that like a
long time ago
that's another one that's on shutter
they added a bunch of john carpenter yes
there's a rumor according to keith david
keith david said that that got pulled
out of the theaters pretty quickly
because a certain kind of people
uh didn't like it
and i was like what is he talking about
at the time they came out some some
people in hollywood interpreted they
lived to be about the the jewish
american community
uh i don't know if it is or not it's
just
absolutely not that's not and actually
even at the time that wasn't what i
interpreted as keith david keith david
said that they thought that that's what
it was
that was i don't know i don't know if
that's the case i kind of feel like it
was i don't know if it was like hugely
successful in the theaters at the time
but it did actually get a big cult
following later
and john carpenter came out
later and said well during the 80s like
he was kind of talking about like reagan
republicans that's what he was talking
about and i'm going to say well a lot of
people say that that was the cover story
but because you can twist and turn
anything
but um
i'll tell you i'm going to say this
about keith dave
being a young
guy my dad when i said i was oh i'll say
i was a young boy okay i don't know how
i remember how old i was maybe 14 13 14.
my dad
took me to see uh the thing
which starred
kurt russell i call him krussel and
keith david and those two dudes
were kind of like
in a way role models for a young tom
ross [ __ ]
both of them were where i like how you
refer to yourself in the third person
yeah yeah i'm doing what i'm doing
[Laughter]
keith david i never would have thought
keith david would be a voice-over dude
over the times but he's got a [ __ ]
bad ass voice keith david [ __ ]
impressed the [ __ ] out of me so did so
did kurt russell
and i love that movie because those both
those two dudes [ __ ] survived it at
the very end
it was a [ __ ] masterpiece man
that movie was a [ __ ] masterpiece i
mean that's still easily
one of my top five favorite and probably
always will yeah to be honest with you
yeah [ __ ]
my favorite white dude crustle
my favorite white my favorite black dude
keith david
keith david keith dave they're my
favorite black dude
uh him and [ __ ] um uh
do [ __ ] uh [ __ ] man now
do from predator one uh
dylan guy who played dylan uh
he was also in rocky [ __ ] come on y'all
know who he is
he played dylan he played [ __ ] um
apollo creed
oh [ __ ]
that's that actor's name he was also in
the mandalorian
i know
you don't remember his name i do but uh
i think it's funny that like that's not
him i could remember it
oh [ __ ] never mind jimmy's gonna [ __ ]
with me yeah
i said was keith david played uh mary's
stepdad and there's something about mary
yeah i mean keith david he was in
uh
one of the recent creep show episodes
too like on shutter so he's like still
around yeah carl weather carl weathers
yeah he was also in action jackson
remember action jackson
there was never a [ __ ] sequel to
action jackson saw that [ __ ] in the
[ __ ] theater man
and there was never a sequel to it
well you know
yeah carl
carl with us
he's a cool guy yeah yeah good looking
dude man this looking had a fantastic
physique
good abs
[ __ ] he made that movie man
[ __ ] biceps and [ __ ]
that was back when men were men they
were riding too you know what i mean it
was [ __ ] that's how it was that's how
it was back then
it was exactly sorry men are still men
nowadays men are still man but they're
not really not like grandpa yeah they do
well i'm just talking about this i'm
talking about in the movies i'm talking
about in the movies yeah they're still
doing it nowadays too not as much
i think they are they're just not like
not talking about it they're not as big
as they were
yeah
well it all has to do with trends yeah
like is that really
uh desirable like for particular roles
that that that even thing is you make it
desirable you make it there's a [ __ ]
carl's episode that he did for
mandalorian season two was [ __ ] one
of the best
episodes too because he directed that
episode i think they have a season two
cooking carl's [ __ ]
he he's talented he's a he's talented
like
on the level of [ __ ] stallone
but i guess he just didn't get the
chance he didn't have the backing and
[ __ ] the way hollywood as [ __ ] up
as the studios are right now i'd like to
see some more
[ __ ] carl weathers [ __ ] directed
stuff because he's at the age now where
he needs to be directed
uh camp guy said carl weather's funny in
arrested development cameos yeah i agree
honestly
i don't think you've ever seen arrested
development i've seen it um
you might really dig arrested
development actually it's a sitcom
sort of
but
i don't know i think you'd really like
it it's kind of like a dark comedy yeah
um
[Music]
i don't know i i don't know how you feel
about it but i think it's [ __ ]
hilarious but yeah he had some like
cameos on that as well
uh yeah camp guy said arrested
development is the funny show ever i
mean it's definitely up there it's
definitely up there that's one of the
funniest shows ever made
but like i said i don't know if you'd
like it or if you'd hate it it's kind of
like one of those things man but i
thought it was storms going crazy out
there here
i know well like i said it's florida i'm
used to it yeah uh danny rowling said
tom put on the sexual tyrannosaurus hat
i got to say
defcon too yeah
he's talking you have the black one on
though he want he wants to oh [ __ ] man
okay put a wig on i ain't no i ain't
playing this we're at the end of the
show not time for that it's not the end
yeah 30 rock is also funny i will admit
i will admit
i mean but probably i don't know man
like
i'm not a
i'm not a big like connoisseur or fan of
like sitcoms but
yeah arrested development was super
funny 30 rock was super funny also
michael kane wig for the grand finale
he's not gonna do that he's like in one
of those moods
they're asking for the michael caine wig
for the finale
see the difference
you can't tell the difference y'all
that's what i mean maybe she should put
the hair
put the curly wig on oh we might do it
we might do it i don't see the wig it's
in there somewhere i swear to god
either hanging up or it's on the upper
shelf or i mean it's a small closet you
can figure it out right
nope
he can't figure it out stop all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] talking
she's down there talking [ __ ] it's a
very small closet tom i don't see my
golden cane wig
i don't see it you gotta find it
you find it
well you come back here and like be in
the thing and i'll find it all fine
there's no michael caine wig in there
it's in there i i promise i didn't see
it all the wigs are in there i didn't
see it all the wigs are in there
see what everybody's talking about
okay
yeah
yeah they're since pookie stole the wig
to sleep in it i mean they're talking
about arrested development
you should probably watch that you might
like it i've never seen isn't that a
whole series though it is a series i'm
not trying to watch no series no it's
funny how many episodes are in it um i
don't know it was on for like several
seasons oh [ __ ]
i still haven't seen [ __ ] better call
saul everybody
she says i hadn't seen anything
pokey don't tear it up she's tearing up
she's not here she's now [ __ ]
you found it yep no you did yeah i did
it's right here
right here
she didn't find it
where was it
right where i said it was
it was not where you said it was yeah it
was
it was in the [ __ ] closet well it was
in a closet but yeah it's up on that
first shelf i told you it was on the
upper shelf okay
it's on the okay i'm gonna put the
michael caine wig on
i'm getting ready to unleash the hand
is he [ __ ] you
yeah hold on hold on
put it you got to get in character you
gotta get careful getting king
there you go
is he [ __ ] you tell me
oh so i see yeah yeah
[Laughter]
i leave and then you start [ __ ] him
yeah of course of course okay so like
but now though now that we've done jaws
the revenge yeah you should do some
hoagie [ __ ]
what's a hoagie
hoagie was the name of the character
that oh
yeah i'm thinking of [ __ ] subway
sandwich
hoagie was the name of the character
that michael kane played in jaws 4. oh
yeah yeah that's right that's right that
light just flashed randomly yeah that
[ __ ] was uh no because the [ __ ]
lightning that [ __ ] was emp that uh
actually uh no hoagie out of [ __ ] um
jaws 4 was just generic
if you ask me he didn't he made no
impression at all the only thing that
like
i mean we talked about this on the jaws
4 thing but the only thing that made an
impression uh was that he just like let
random ass people including children and
people that had no prior experience in
flying planes or anything
um live the plane
well i'm just gonna sit here like this
and we're just gonna crash into the
earth unless you figure some [ __ ] out
and i'd be like [ __ ] this is not well
that's actually there's actually
something that's that what the [ __ ] was
that
oh the power must have gone out okay
yeah because the the printer just went
off and then came back on even pookie's
looking at it what is that like but yeah
so was i well i have a printer right
down there for like to print the uh you
know the postage for the packages and
stuff
and it just went off and came back on
and like made all kind of noise
so you know no i'm not worried about uh
i'm not worried about jaws four
oscar says saw the hand great movie it
is a great one okay so you saw i kind of
feel like a lot of people haven't seen
it and yeah look at this wig is like fun
yeah
when did you see that
it's oscar who
just got perez perez okay who's always
here oh yeah
we talked about that before yeah i think
he said he saw that a couple days ago
we didn't have time to redress it though
if you notice
the hand
is exactly the opposite of conan
and the dude that is [ __ ] the artist
who is like controlling the hand
it he is the conan artist
it's meta
you know
uh it's uh what was his name he goes
condo no no what was his name
no not condo what's his name
what was the name of that [ __ ]
character
i forgot
jenny's not helping me do you remember
name of that character that [ __ ] uh
the guy from the hand was drawing
who's his name
i can't remember
yeah but it's basic it's basically uh
conan
but conan is like kind of like if you
because oliver stone
and
milius
were working on these movies at the same
time conan won and the
hand and they're two different
interpretations
two opposite interpretations of
masculinity
conan
was real masculinity
all right
and then the hand was toxic masculinity
yeah that dude was a duty yeah yeah
well his woman was kind of [ __ ] him
over but she was [ __ ] him over
because he was talking she was [ __ ]
him over because
she was like yeah i'm sick of [ __ ]
um she wanted a more like sensitive dude
yeah that wasn't like like beating her
ass all the time yeah well he never beat
her ass though no but i mean he was just
talking [ __ ] uh he well he was
emotionally abusive yeah and she was
just kind of like well [ __ ] that she was
interested in
he was constantly like [ __ ] on it
and she was just kind of like yeah i
don't really like this because you know
nobody wants to be around somebody's
like [ __ ] on stuff that you like all
the time yeah so that's kind of like
what so even though like he didn't beat
her up until later
he never he never beat her up
well he did kind of smack around like
later on i don't think so no yeah he did
kind of
no no he killed he killed the other girl
yeah which like i said that's that's
the other girl that's not great um and
well he with he thought the hand did it
it was him
but well yeah of course and then he
killed the dude
that's that
linked him to her
it was a good movie
and in the end the hand came out of the
[ __ ]
air return and killed the psychologist
but it was him it was him it was him
well i mean the hand was like the
it was his version of [ __ ] that was
how he imagined should happen yeah it
was an unreliable narrator or or
there was a second way of looking at it
or it was psychokinetic abilities he was
kind of like a sith from star wars where
he was
i kind of feel like the whole thing was
like i said an unreliable narrator
situation where he was just kind of like
that was another part of his psyche that
he didn't want to deal with
right so they're like well i'm gonna
like fob this off on oh it's my severed
hand
killing people and i don't absolutely
have nothing to do with that
you know what i mean i kind of feel like
that's
like you said it's a top it's it's an
indictment of toxic max masculinity and
it's also kind of like
i mean he had ham was about possession
that was about keeping things that's
what i think was good about like the
hand metaphor the hand the metaphor the
hand is very like it's grasping trying
to grasp and you can't keep you're
trying to like grasp things and keep
things and you can't right and i kind of
feel like that was his whole thing like
he couldn't keep hold of his wife he
couldn't let [ __ ] go
and that too right so it was like a
double so that's why i think like the
metaphor about it was like really really
brilliant because there was a lot of
ways that you could interpret that yeah
real masculinity was like conan where
you could let [ __ ] go you could let you
go you could take [ __ ] that came to you
you could fight but you didn't want to
keep something that didn't that didn't
want to be there right that that that
you weren't keeping things like against
their will right now and i kind of feel
like that's yeah the hand he was kind of
showing how that dude like he had like
he had like this iron fist thing like
over his wife yeah and she was like not
having it right which is why she started
i don't think she like [ __ ]
necessarily like [ __ ] around them but
but she got much more interesting yoga
yeah she was trying to get away yeah
trying to hold her yeah and she was just
kind of like look i'm into this other
stuff and you're just making fun of it
so about possession yeah
when you get down to toxic masculinity
true toxic medicine not what some of
these [ __ ] are called now true
masculinity
is about possession
you trying to possess another person
it's not possible
not in the western world and besides
even if you weren't in the western world
why would you want to
why i mean that's a human being yeah
where they want to go so you can't like
if they're not going to like do some
[ __ ] you want to do just because you
want to do it then
you can't make them right but if you
haven't seen oliver stones to hand
it's required view it if you're if
you've been on this show it's great
you'll love it it's great horror movie
great horror movie it freaked me out
when i was a kid yeah when i was kid i
was like [ __ ] man his hand's going
around killing people
it's not though i mean well
it's it's it's it's it's ambiguous
but that's
that's the best thing about like
horror movies
it's ambiguous you could see it as like
just a horror movie about like a
disembodied hand or you could see it as
like a metaphor about
this is that dude's subconscious desires
to possess and he doesn't realize that
that's kind of what he's doing
yeah um
so he kind of like dissociates yeah
so
i kind of that's how i read it you don't
have to read it like that but that's
kind of how that's what it really is
well yeah that's what it really is is
that he's murdering people he's blaming
it on this hand and he's just like yeah
like i said he's dissociating oh that's
not me yeah that's my disembodied hand
that's doing it doing this [ __ ] right
that's his way of absolving himself like
responsibility well yeah that's because
dudes that [ __ ] kill people for those
reasons say they're not to blame right
and that's that's exactly well that's
what i mean that's what's great about
that movie is because stone genius right
well and we've talked about like a lot
of serial killers that had they had to
come up with these like elaborate right
stories about why they weren't
responsible
for the [ __ ] that they did for whatever
reason
and this is kind of like like that but
fictionalized yeah and like supernatural
a little bit because he kind of sees it
as like his disembodied hand yeah and
he's an artist as well yeah he's an
artist and he drawn cartoon strips and
he draws a character like conan
who's not like him at all okay which
that that's
that's a great error that's a great
angle but what was the name of that
character it wasn't rastan that was the
[ __ ] getting butthorked
it wasn't condo condo was from [ __ ]
i'm trying to remember i can't really
call him
[ __ ] man it's been so long since we've
seen that movie you couldn't they
couldn't say conan because well yeah
because that's copyrighted that's robbie
howard yeah
but
yeah and robert e howard was not like
this guy robert e howard was a young guy
who was a mama's boy really
and when his mom although he wrote some
great [ __ ] [ __ ] bro great [ __ ] i mean
i've read a lot of stuff robert e howard
tales and stuff conan was robert e
robert who
robert e howard was a texan back in the
day and his fantasy alter ego was conan
he wished he was conan he said when he
was writing those stories this this
shadowy spirit of conan was watching him
write them and [ __ ]
and you know [ __ ] i i i i [ __ ] i
appreciate everything he did he did make
a big impact on west on american culture
and strangely enough when his mom died
he
started to fall apart and committed
suicide a guy who wrote conan that
happens a lot with yeah like that yeah
yeah he was not a kind of guy that could
be by himself
you know
but he wanted to be a lot of guys that
are like that are kind of
that happens a lot yeah and conan was
his super ego
that was who he wanted to be like
and he wasn't a little weasely guy he
was a big dude he's a big texan
just that's that's not who he was
internally on a spiritual level
this kind of stuff fascinates me though
because
so many dudes that have written stuff
that is like iconic
in the horror of sci-fi whatever genre
were dudes like that
uh you know like hp lovecraft people
like that they were kind of like
i mean they were very very sheltered
they were writing from their fantasy and
it's interesting to me because
i don't know i guess i'm a writer myself
but i've never really approached things
from that standpoint
and i'm not really sure if i don't know
maybe it's a different thing like maybe
dudes that write like right for
different reasons
than
than what i do
because i kind of feel like a lot of um
i don't know like literature that
survives nowadays like for like horror
and sci-fi like the guys that wrote it
had um
issues
like i said
like lovecraft or
like robert e howard or something and
they wrote like amazing [ __ ] but then
like when you look into their life
um
you can kind of like go back into like
why they wrote what they wrote
particularly like it was kind of like
their
uh
i don't know like i guess like a fantasy
extrapolation of themselves like stuff
that they could never be
and so they wrote these like fantasy and
that like related that kind of like
resonated with people
and
so that's i don't know that's like
really interesting to me like why
particular things resonate with
particular audiences
um
i don't know i just
honestly like i
write fiction but i just write about
stuff that
i think it's scary or that i had
nightmares about or something i don't
particularly care if like other people
think it's scary or anything like that i
don't really think about that
so
it's interesting to me that
that's kind of such a big thing i think
about it oh thank you very much victor
sorry i'm late start over thanks vic
[Laughter]
we can't start over we don't mind i mean
we're already like pretty [ __ ] at this
point but i want to kind of go back and
if you guys watch my book reviews
you guys have probably seen my reviews
of like some uh
some [ __ ] that was but like by [ __ ]
uh richard layman
and i talk about him a lot because he's
a very interesting case to me
this is a dude he's passed away he
passed away many years ago
but
he seems to me the quintessential
example of a dude that
was seemingly financially successful
uh culturally successful
by writing stuff that was probably
just his like fantasies made flesh like
he was like writing his fantasies down
and then a lot of people were like yeah
absolutely and they were like buying
that stuff
now
i've read a bunch of his stuff and i'm
just kind of like
i mean i'm a girl reading this stuff and
i've had some comments
that
one of the comments that i got somebody
like subscribing to my you know my book
review thing was like i'm really glad
that you approached richard layman
in a way that a lot of
uh female reviewers don't
um i don't take his [ __ ] entirely
seriously because to me it seems like a
lot of like just adolescent fantasy
like made
into a novel uh that was pretty much his
entire career to me like yeah it's toxic
it's whatever but it's also like kind of
funny to me and it's like kind of
amusing
i can understand like if you don't like
it because it is pretty
some of the times like i read it i'm
just kind of like okay
uh i i see where you're going with that
but it's i don't know
so
i don't know
where was that going with that i don't
know
i don't even remember but i'm just
saying that
we were talking about uh conan and all
that kind of stuff i kind of feel like a
lot of
really iconic
sci-fi fantasy horror literature
came from dudes that
had issues
and they were filling the gaps in their
life
with their fiction which like i said i'm
not [ __ ] on that like a lot of
people do that
uh well but the fact that it resonated
with people i mean that's interesting to
me well it's because if you don't like
that sure that's what i mean that's i
mean the reason that and that's why it's
interesting because in terms of howard
howard was trying to envision the
ultimate male
because he didn't see himself as the
ultimate male so he's making the
ultimate male
in the ultimate environment sure which
is like a prehistoric barbaric
primal environment
and he writes stories
about this guy in that environment
and that and he's not the only guy that
think that you know would respond to
that that's what i'm saying
well that's what's interesting to me is
that there's like a big not only that
there's like a large contingent of
uh fantasy sci-fi horror writers that
wrote from that context but also that
there was like a large audience for that
because i mean i'm a horror writer too
but i don't really come at it from that
angle yeah you know what i'm saying but
that's interesting to me
now howard's version of conan
was not milius's version of conan with
arnold schwarzenegger he conan was big
but he wasn't that big okay
um and uh the stories weren't quite the
same
even though
some people would say yeah but in the
books conan wasn't like that he was a
lot smarter and a lot more verbose and
strategic
but i'm going to go ahead and defend
milius because
part one of milius's version of the
conan and the barbarian was conan's
origin story he wasn't fully grown
really
so
a lot of the cool [ __ ] that evidently he
did in the books later which i haven't
read the books but a lot of cool [ __ ]
that he did later
um
sprung from this original story that's
what millies is talking about his basic
training his his origin story kind of
like batman begins that's
so it's a legitimate story if you ask me
i mean
you might like some of howard's fiction
i've read them like uh it gets some
audio books admittedly i've not read any
of the conan stuff but he wrote a lot of
fantasy stuff for weird tales the fans
and i have like read a lot of that i'm
not now i will admit that i'm not super
into fantasy i'm usually like more like
a horror gal
some fantasy is good so i have read like
a large portion of like uh howard's
stuff from weird tales people are saying
tom looks so young with hair
but uh
look
i i need to listen to i need to listen
to some conan that's what i'm telling
you you should probably like listen to
it and uh honestly i think you can
probably get them on youtube yeah and
the most people tell me that or assuming
most of the fans i don't say most people
most of the fans
that i've read talking about
con
milius's version of conan they're like
that's not so much like conan that's
more kind of like milius's other
character named crawl
i think was it crawl
yeah well they made a movie called no
not crawl it's the one that [ __ ] that
christian dude was in it wasn't called
crow
what was his name
crawl was more of a science fiction
fantasy
um
i think it did start with a k i'm not it
wasn't true
some of the fans michael schaefer says
cult cull that's what it was called
call yeah evidently call was
closer
to conan the barbarian families than
conan was cold that's what it was
and that uh that guy uh what was his
name
uh he was kind of known as a christian
guy back in the 90s uh who was in i
think he did uh
samson oh well this is a television
series move hercules he did hercules
television series
kevin sorbos oh kevin sarvo yeah corvus
oh sorbo okay that's over kevin sorbo
did a a call he did a bunch of like
christian movies like later yeah yeah he
was in like a bunch of like creationists
sorbos evidently did a cull movie that
was um
some of the cull fans are like [ __ ]
yeah that's kind of it but not that
budget it might a lot more budget more
kind of like [ __ ]
call kevin sorbo you can't assure about
yeah well he was in like uh what was
that show called like hercules that
adventure could do or whatever the [ __ ]
it was called and then he got recruited
into a bunch of i don't know like maybe
he believes this stuff but yeah he got
recruited into a bunch of like
creationist
propaganda movies that were on pure
flicks like god's not dead he was just
trying to make money dude was trying to
make money
now in a couple of those yeah
now um oh what's her name the chick
from she was from um
she's from gladiator that was really
good what was her name she did uh
she did kind of like a female barbarian
movie she had a little female sidekick
my friend my friend my little gothic
friend
um melissa loved that [ __ ] series
you guys remember it's back in the 90s
damn
and uh
melissa was bi so she was constantly
like i know those two are getting it on
looking i don't remember the name of
that [ __ ] she's shipping this to you
yes was it lucy lucy lawless yeah what
was the name of that [ __ ] she was
also on ash versus evil dead yeah which
if you haven't seen that please go watch
out yes we all did it's so good back
back in the 90s my friend [ __ ]
melissa it was this little cute guy
chick she was like [ __ ] i know lucy
lawless and that blonde are getting it
on because you know i'd be hitting that
this or that she'd be super hot what was
the name of that [ __ ] what was the
name of that [ __ ] uh character that
she did
xena xena cena warrior princess that's
right well yeah that was the whole thing
with her and
but i gotta say like she ended up much
cooler because she actually ended up
being on like the new evil dead series
yeah whereas kevin sorbo ended up being
in like weird like creationist
propaganda with [ __ ] kirk cameron and
people melissa [ __ ] loves seeing a
warrior princess and [ __ ] oh a lot of
people love it and her interpretation
was is that it was lesbianic porn and
she said she is yeah yeah yeah it is
she [ __ ] loved that [ __ ] it was back
in the 90s i never watched it but she
loved it she was like yeah watching a
warrior princess is like no no she would
put on dead can dance albums i mean it's
pretty yeah yeah i don't know if it's
like overt about it but it's i don't
think it's over it's not overt i mean
it's just one level coming from over it
there she yeah
you should have heard the [ __ ] she would
say and then she would she was a big art
bell fan y'all would love her [ __ ]
i can't get her on now though she's
[ __ ] living up in mississippi and
[ __ ] she's got a boyfriend and
[ __ ] living in her little witch witch
house and [ __ ] but it'd be great to have
her on she was [ __ ] funny man back in
the 90s but i think she's kind of still
stuck in the 90s i haven't talked
haven't really had a long conversation
with well you one time she called me one
time she called me and she said was that
was that your girlfriend remember that
oh is that your girlfriend that was
melissa back in the uh probably about
five six years ago back at the old house
i don't remember that
somebody video chatted me out of the
blue and it was melissa and it says my
friend melissa he she didn't know who it
was
she didn't know who it was well how
would i know i don't know her so i'm
just like sitting there doing this no no
no i was living in my regular life she's
like no it's my friend melissa she
didn't even know who it was
i was probably teasing you like oh
you're like oh you're just
i'm like oh no once i settled it out
you're like oh okay
it was my ex-wife's for girlfriend
friend they weren't they weren't a
couple but they were a friend
victor says xena and gabrielle kissed in
the show yeah yeah yes it made every
christian's mad back in the 90s yeah see
i remember that yeah yeah i remember it
being like not super overtly lesbian but
pretty like just right under the surface
lesbian and i kind of feel like that
made a lot of people mad but um you know
melissa loved that [ __ ] she knew all the
[ __ ] story she knew all the [ __ ]
plot lines
everything all the outfits
she you know and she was she was cool
lizzie lawless is badass she loved lucy
lawless she liked the gabrielle
the blonde chick and everything and she
was
just a cute
in those days in the 90s she was a cute
girl chick in her [ __ ] 20s
who um knew how to dress had real good
taste in music and she loved that
[ __ ] she loved that
a lot of people loved that man and she
was just this black people gulfport
mississippi goth girl that
lived in a house that her dad built for
her that looked like a little doll house
it looked like the [ __ ] baba yaga's
house she was like a little witch it had
chicken feet it almost had chicken feet
it should have chicken feet
yeah my dream is to build a house
that has chicken yeah she had a little
bitty [ __ ] house that her dad built
for she's still living in it how [ __ ]
rad would that be to have a house on
chicken feet yeah michael schaefer said
jenny do you like the seaberry quinn
tails from uh stories from weird tales
i've read a couple of those and i've
liked what i've read but i haven't like
read enough of them to
really make a judgment but you know i'll
get back to that i do really like a lot
of those old weird tales i'm kind of
working my way through
the old weird tales
because i don't know if you know but
wikipedia has a bunch of them
uh archived
so some of the stories
i don't know some years like some years
they have like all of the stories from
weird tales and you can read them for
free but some of them they don't because
of copyright issues
but
i try to like read all the ones that i
can so i have read a couple of those and
i do really like them victor said jenny
your shirt is cool as [ __ ] thank you
very much
i actually got this from
an actual store
uh from fye
fye i got it at the mall which is across
the street from our
movie theater
and they have all of these kind of i
have several of these i have a cthulhu
one
i have a halloween one
i have a creature from the black lagoon
they have like a bunch of other ones too
like the same i think it's called riot
society actually
and they have like a whole bunch of
different shirts they have an alien one
they have a jaws one they have all kind
of leg crap but they like the designs
are really cool so i bought like a bunch
of them when i was there one day like
before we were
seeing a movie yeah kevin sorbo
he's a conspiracy theorist now yeah
um
he was in
he played the atheist professor
in god's not dead he might have been in
the second one too i didn't watch the
actual movie i just watched like other
channels like making fun of it because
i'm not gonna sit through that come on
um
but yeah i don't know if he actually
believes that [ __ ] or if he's just like
trying to get a paycheck
so what happened
nothing oh there's about paychecks i'm
like paychecks hell yeah
uh juana chase velasquez says you two
are looking beautiful well thank you
very much thank you very much what
where'd you where's your curly wig go oh
i took that off it got too hot
i've been wearing a wig all night i'm
gonna see i'm gonna see if i can find a
picture of melissa and i actually have
hair
that i have to put under a wig cap
to put this wig on
you have a bald head yeah it's okay it's
all good
it is all good
can't nack another friday the cocktail
yeah that's what i called it you guys
got that damn right i hope i didn't miss
much oh my god seriously we've been on
for three hours and 15 minutes at this
point damn we are both
pretty inebriated yeah i don't even
remember what all we talked about what
did we talk about all the time
i don't know
horror movies
uh
i don't even remember i don't remember
we try we try
uh for tom and jenny which is better
return of the living dead
or day of the dead 1985. ooh
honestly i have to say that's kind of
like a tough decision to make because
they're kind of like i don't know
they're kind of different movies return
to the living dead
was made as
a comedy
whereas day of the dead is funny
but not necessarily made as a comedy
it's made like more overtly it's like a
horror movie
so
okay i'm gonna say
as a viewing experience
i'm gonna go return a living dead now if
it was dawn of the dead that'd be
different
but day of the dead
i love that movie
but
for re-watch value for entertainment
value jump poop
i think that
return a living dead is like more fun
and if you got me on a different day i
might say something different but you
know what are you drinking jenny uh it's
a
[Music]
it's a screwdriver
vodka and orange juice
danny rolling says return all day night
for me yeah i mean
just overall that's like a more fun
movie to watch
it has like better uh re-watch value
of all the george romero movies honestly
like i think the highest uh you know
re-watch value is night of living dead
or dawn of the dead day the dead is good
but it's not usually one that i want to
re-watch all that much so it's just kind
of like if i'm going to watch a zombie
movie
it's going to be one of the early george
romero ones or
we're trying to leave me dead i'm not a
huge fan of zombie movies i have to say
and particularly like nowadays
that every [ __ ] and their mother
has made a zombie movie
and i'm kind of over it honestly i'm not
really into zombies it's just kind of
like i'm not really into vampires
as a genre like if you can
come up with a different angle on it
awesome
but
i don't know it's just it's not really
something if if i'm gonna really get
into something it's usually gonna be
either something
ambiguous or it's gonna be something
like psychological horror
or
ghost stories i'm not like i'm not
really into like monster monster stuff
like vampires or zombies or werewolves
or something like that like i've liked a
lot of those but
you have to work a lot harder
to make me like that you know what i'm
saying because i'm gonna have like some
biases against it like from the from the
start so just saying
and let's see do do do
danny really can't see yet return the
living dead scared the [ __ ] out of me i
mean
the whole [ __ ]
return of living dead started the whole
brains thing
it was not a thing until that movie came
out like vampires eating brains that was
the first iteration of that i need a
good creature feature recommendation
says victor anyone
uh
i don't know if i can help you i don't
know if i can
think of something that you haven't seen
in that
regard because it's not my go-to genre i
think i did
howard the other day power oh yeah what
was his name
what was the name of that one
he was fighting venom
yeah
michael shafer says dog soldiers dog
soldiers is
easily my top five werewolf movies i
mean dog soldiers is so
so good it's so good i just i love that
[ __ ] movie and i'm not really into
werewolf movies as as a whole like i
love american werewolf in london i love
the original wolfman
um other than that i can't really think
of well now the howling is good um late
phases is good that's like a newer one
if you haven't seen that one
but dog soldiers is uh yeah pretty
amazing creature feature creature
feature i'm trying to think i did all
the sinbad movies back in march
i did a whole month of
monster march
and some of the movies i came up with um
like i said it's not usually my genre
i like that like i said i like all kind
of horror movies i will give like
anything a chance if you have a monster
movie that's fine if you have a ghost
movie but it's not like my favorite my
favorite subgenre is usually
psychological horror or
like haunted houses like or ghost spirit
kind of stuff not necessarily demon
possession because that's been done like
a zillion times and i'm not like super
into that but
but i like other stuff i don't you know
i'll give other stuff a chance as well
so creature features i don't know what
was that one that i saw the um [ __ ] i'm
trying to remember like the name of that
one
i know there's been like some bigfoot
ones that i that i thought were kind of
good but
i can't think of like what they were
called now
but i don't know generally i'm not
really into
because i know there's a whole sub genre
of like alien movies there's a whole sub
genre of like bigfoot movies
eh
other than like something like troll
hunter which was amazing
you should actually see trollhunter
troll hunter was so good well it was
because it was a creature feature
crossed with found footage but it was
also kind of like making fun of that but
not in a way that like pissed you off
like in a way that was still like uh
realistic
and i thought that was like such a great
idea because like we're gonna take the
creature feature slash found footage
thing
and we're gonna like take it to the next
level so we're going to norway or
wherever
and we're gonna like make it so that
trolls are real
and the special effects in that were
like really really good so it's like
these trolls come out and like people
are acting as though they're just like
another aspect of the environment
and
i don't know i really i really vibe with
that so if you haven't seen troll hunter
that's a really good one too but
i really like that one generally i don't
like
creature features
or found footage
but
there are a lot of a lot of exceptions
to that a lot of exceptions because like
i said i'm pretty willing to like watch
anything
if other people tell me that it's good
and that i probably like it then i'll
watch it i'm not you know i'm not proud
i'll watch it
i'm just saying
and i'm not well and i'm not so like
locked into one thing like yeah i have
certain uh preferences
but
it's not so much that it's like oh well
i don't like
you know xyz like whatever subgenre that
like i'm not going to watch it i'll
watch pretty much anything
and i'll approach it
with an open mind you know i'm not kind
of like oh well i'm not gonna like this
or blah blah i'll just like you know
show it to me if it's good then okay
so i don't know
what are they cut is anybody coming up
with anything yeah doc soldiers is good
i love found footage too i'm i'm on the
fence about found footage like found
footage
can be good but
there's so much like crappy found
footage that it's really hard to find
good ones
found footage i tend to like
found footage movies that are more
mockumentary style
so
less found footage like oh my god we're
filming this crazy thing that happened
um and more like hey i'm making a
documentary about this thing and then
[ __ ] went uh you know exponentially
sideways
so
stuff that i like that found footage
movies that i like tend to be stuff
that's mockumentaries like lake mungo or
the bay or something like that where
there's some reason for people to be
filming stuff because i kind of feel
like one of the things that i can't get
past and found footage is like why the
[ __ ] are these [ __ ] still
filming this
uh when
every normal person on earth would have
been like why are we still like carrying
this camera around
so the fact that you still have oh and
uh taking of deborah logan that's
another uh mockumentary that's actually
really good
but
i don't know like i'm trying to think of
like some other good found footage as
well so below that was a good one
what are you doing it's ridiculous no
it's just uploading a bunch of [ __ ]
oh my god messages going yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i guess i just got a good got a good
connection or something picture said the
bay was good honestly like the bay was
one of my favorite mockumentaries
i mean it had like it had like a really
good balance between like realism and
like really really gross
body horror i mean like something that's
like a [ __ ]
it looked like a roly-poly but [ __ ] up
that took over your mouth and like took
over your tongue
it was like a parasite
and it like took over this whole like
town like over fourth of july we i was
like that yeah i was into that that was
like really good
um the vhs movies are also good i mean
some of the segments better than others
but
most of them like pretty good at least
that i remember but like i said it's not
usually
i usually won't watch found footage
unless somebody tells me hey this is a
really good one because it's not usually
my genre of choice
and like i said if it's found footage i
tend to like mockumentaries more than
found footage
i wasn't even
i liked the first paranormal activity
not saying that i think that was like
really cool but
i was a little bit when i first saw the
first paranormal activity i haven't seen
like i've seen a couple of the sequels
and i was just kind of like okay
whatever but um the first one
was good but it was a little bit
underwhelming i kind of feel like i
don't
i don't know i don't really get why like
so people so many people were like
freaked out by it
but
like i said everybody's different like i
get
weirded out by different things then so
the found footage thing like doesn't
always like do stuff for me but
i don't know everyone's mileage may vary
i'm not like [ __ ] on other people's
like
taste or anything just saying
just saying
don't put your you put your uh nerd
glasses on my it's birth control your
birth control glasses birth control
glasses you know that's what they used
to call the um
in the uk
the glasses that they gave you like on
the nhs yeah
control glasses yeah i think that you
can never get laid with those glasses
well i'm sure they probably still did
but
i like those glasses though
okay well what's the matter with you
what time is it it's uh
9 21. okay it's time for me to go ahead
and check up
i'm going to start making this something
to eat what do you want to eat
what do you got um
want a hamburger
sure okay what else you got
what else you got to go with the
hamburger um
you got any chips or fries no
no no i don't have much anything i'll
figure something out or salad
no had thrown the salad out went bad
yeah it went bad
wait i got it
two of those big old things i got two of
those big old things a coleslaw that i
could turn into salad the first one we
went through the second one just kind of
rotted in the danny says make egg salad
time
uh no i can't oh egg salad or potato
salad
um now i don't have the stuff for it
it's so good though come on now egg
salad's a waste of eggs because i have
no it's so good no i have to use eggs
for other things we eat them for
breakfast
okay okay
all right
we're gonna have burgers i guess yeah
we're in burgers all right we're gonna
eat what we have all right so we'll be
back sunday
and we will be talking about
no country for old men
which i've seen like multiple times but
i don't think tom has ever seen so i'm
very very curious to see how he's gonna
react to this because
i love this movie so i don't but he's
never seen it so i don't really know or
he's seen it and he didn't really pay
attention so we'll see how it goes so uh
again felt like thank you very much
xander for sending us that so we're
gonna talk about that on sunday
uh so yeah
hopefully you guys have a good weekend
up until we see you again
and we will be back on sunday evening
and we'll see you guys again then
so we will see you
later on